avait il confié
fini les cheveux longs pour certains
d'entre vous bonsoir et bienvenue pour
cette nouvelle et dernière version
confiné enfin confiné on ne sait pas
finalement de ce facebook live à c'est à
dire du téléphone sonne sans téléphone
et espérer que les réponses à quelques
questions alors comme d'habitude y en a
beaucoup plus que je devais pouvoir en
prendre et je vais faire quelque chose
de parfaitement démocratique est
frustrant pour certains qui est de
privilégier celles qui ont reçu le plus
de fautes
voilà vous voyez à la question est ce
que vous devriez pas faire de la
politique il ya la réponse et si j'en
fais je prends ce qui a reçu le plus de
voix
alors la question qui arrive en tête et
donc commencer par celle là qui en plus
si elle est intéressante ce qui ne gâche
rien concerne le conseil qu'on pourrait
donner à quelqu'un qui doit choisir son
orientation professionnelle et il ya une
question qui ressemble beaucoup aux
enfers ou plus exactement qui est
connexe de prendre les deux ensembles
qui était quels seront les métiers
utiles à la société d'après demain alors
répondre à cette question est une chose
qui n'est pas facile parce que en fait
répondre à cette question c'est gérer un
décalage temporel quelqu'un qui doit
choisir son orientation professionnelle
aujourd'hui s'il ne veut pas se
retrouver dans un état très désagréable
qui va concerner quelques millions de
personnes supplémentaires dans quelques
mois c'est pas du chômage
eh bien il est préférable qu'ils
prennent quelque chose qui derrière va
lui permettre d'avoir un travail
alors ce travail doit être à son compte
on peut imaginer que c'est un travail
qui lui permet de se lancer dans la vie
mais par contre il faut absolument que
ce soit quelque chose qui lui permettent
d'assurer sa subsistance c'est comme ça
en général qu'on soit le travail et les
métiers qui seront utiles après demain
sont pas nécessairement utile
aujourd'hui parce qu'aujourd'hui la
société n'est pas nécessairement
organisé pour que ces métiers soient
faciles à exercer en particulier toute
la question de la transition
c'est bien d'aller vers un état qui est
celui d'aujourd'hui qu'on peut
considérer comme étant non satisfaisant
vers un état qui sera plus satisfaisant
ou carrément très satisfaisant
qu'on aura demain après demain enfin en
tout cas pas aujourd'hui donc la
question de cette affaire d'orientation
professionnelle c'est finalement est ce
qu'il ya des métiers qui permettent de
trouver dès aujourd'hui un employeur
l'employeur pouvoir être soi même et qui
pourront soit faire progresser une
activité qui va prendre de plus en plus
de place et qu'on considère comme étant
utile soit s'insérer dans une activité
qui aujourd'hui n'est pas configuré de
manière utile mais qu'on peut
accompagner vers quelque chose qui est
utile alors je vais prendre d'entrée de
jeu un exemple dans la deuxième
catégorie aujourd'hui une bonne partie
de l'activité du bâtiment construit en
consiste pardon à construire des
bâtiments neufs dans un monde qui
doivent devenir de plus en plus sobres
en énergie on peut considérer que de
rajouter des boîtes ce qui demande de
l'énergie pour les construire puisqu'il
faut faire du ciment avec dassier est
que quand vous regardez d'à peu près on
peut pas faire quelques centaines de
milliers de logements par an avec
lambois n'ya pas le bois pour ça la
regarde et 44 passes et bien aujourd'hui
donc le métier de la construction
consiste à faire tourner des aciéries
des cimenteries à imperméabiliser les
sols à bétonner a rajouté soit dit en
passant encore plus de béton exactement
d'imperméabilisation pour la voirie que
pour les bâtiments lui-même c'est-à-dire
que quand on construit aujourd'hui c'est
souvent une voie d'accès qui a permis à
blyes ain permis d' un ppr mobilisent
voilà je vais y arriver le plus de le
plus de surface et non pas les bâtiments
eux-mêmes
donc quand on construit aujourd'hui on
nivet et on rajoute des boîtes pour
l'essentiel on pourrait imaginer que le
métier de la construction demain
consiste non pas à rajouter des boîtes
mais à s'occuper des boîtes existantes
de plus en plus alors en fait à ce
moment ça sera plus de la construction
ce sera plutôt de la rénovation
ça demande pas nécessairement les mêmes
compétences par exemple quand on fait du
gros oeuvre
c'est compliqué derrière de fer d'arrêt
de bastien lamon compétences par contre
si on devient combier ou électricien
baba fois qu'on travaille dans un
bâtiment neuf faut qu'on travaille dans
un bâtiment en cours de rénovation ça ça
fonctionne
donc il ya des métiers qui peuvent
concerner les secteurs d'activité qui
aujourd'hui ne vont pas dans le bon sens
mais qui pourrait y aller demain un
autre exemple pour rester dans le btp
aujourd'hui une partie du btp consiste à
entretenir des voies routières pour les
faire passer des voitures pourrait très
bien imaginer que plutôt que
d'entretenir ces voies pour y faire
passer des voitures
on cherche à reconvertir ces voies
pourrait faire passer des vélos vous
pourrez faire passer des rames
pourquoi enfin des eaux à ce moment vous
avez un métier qui reste à peu près le
même c'est à dire qu'il s'agit toujours
de gérer et d'entretenir des
infrastructures sauf que voulait destiné
à quelque chose de très différent
donc il ya déjà un certain nombre de
métiers pour lesquels il faut faire un
pari sur l'avenir sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui s'est mis au service
d'une activité et qu'on peut considérer
comme n'allant pas dans le bon sens mais
qui pourrait être réorientés demain vers
quelque chose qui est le plus pertinent
et là il ya une sous d'autres cieux
questions ou deuxième question on va
dire qui va avec
qui est ce que c'est plus facile de
faire bouger ce genre d' entité de
l'intérieur de l'extérieur donc vous
êtes jeune vous avez envie que l'on
puisse se déplacer à vélo quand vous
vous dites très bien je vais aller dans
les sociétés qui entretiennent les
infrastructures routières et je vais
faire en sorte que demain il y en ait un
plus grand nombre qui s'occupe de faire
des pistes cyclables ou les entretenir
la bonne question c'est est-ce que vous
êtes plus utiles dedans dehors
voilà donc il ya aussi une deuxième
question on va dire à partir du moment
où le faire un métier qu'on considère
comme servante cause il ya bien
évidemment la question de savoir si on
doit rentrer dans le secteur bien rester
en dehors du secteur faire un autre
métier et puis s'occuper de midi donc là
c'est des métiers qui encore une fois
peuvent trouver un employeur tout de
suite et on espère que l'activité se
réorientera demain après il ya d'autres
métiers pour lesquels il faut espérer
que le volume d'activité va augmenter
demain par exemple il ya un certain
nombre de métiers dans l'agriculture qui
sont des métiers qui seront utiles pour
demain parce que on va y revenir quand
on parlera des villes on va y revenir
quand on parlera de la productivité du
travail
il est vraisemblable que dans un monde
avec une activité pendant une quantité
une quantité d'énergie utilisée qui
baisse on va augmenter la part de
travail manuel et notamment la part de
travail agricole
mais cette activité agricole ne pas
arriver trop tôt parce que tant qu'on
est en concurrence avec les machines et
bien on n'arrive pas à gagner sa vie en
travaillant dans l'agriculture
donc là on fait un pari par exemple si
on va dans ce secteur là qui est que le
secteur évoluera à la bonne vitesse
certaines gens qui s'installent ou du
mal parce qu'ils trouvent pas les terres
voilà donc ce n'est pas nécessairement
très simple après il ya un certain
nombre d'autres métiers dans des dents
des usages qui aujourd'hui n'existe
carrément pas où existe très peu donc la
bonne question c'est est-ce qu'il faut
se préparer pour quelque chose en
faisant un pari en disant quand j'aurai
fini ma formation on en aura besoin
et c'est évidemment quelque chose de
difficile si on essaye de donner des
orientations un peu général finalement
qu'est-ce qui reste utile aux hommes
quelles que soient les circonstances et
bien c'est essentiellement la forme qui
change si on en revient à cette
excellente théorie ou cette excellente
exposé plus tôt qui est fait par
sébastien colère sur la façon dont
fonctionne notre cervelle on cherche
toujours à assouvir exactement à mettre
notre cortex au service d'un certain
nombre de besoins primaires qui sont en
danger donc les gens qui s'occupent de
fournir à manger normalement il devrait
avoir une utilité dans la société
les gens qui nous aident à nous habiller
et à nous déplacer qui sont aussi des
besoins raisonnablement primé en voilier
en ce moment on est privé de déplacement
on trouve pas ça très drôle soit aussi
des gens qui devrait avoir une place et
le déplacement évidemment voit se faire
sous contrainte faible quantité
d'énergie disponible ou de faibles
émissions de co2 il ya un sujet
important qui est de s'inscrire dans le
groupe d'être reconnue de monter dans la
hiérarchie enfin tout c'est toutes ces
choses là là c'est difficile de savoir
exactement quels sont les quels sont les
métiers qui qui tourne autour de sarah
mais probablement quand on voit
l'augmentation en ce moment de
l'engagement associatif exactement
l'augmentation à tendance de
l'engagement associatif tous les métiers
qui vont autour de faire du bien
d'autrui
autant qu'on arrive à leur trouver un
modèle solvables sondés sont des métiers
qui ont probablement un débouché
croissant on va dire demain voilà donc
les métiers qui sont proches des besoins
de base
alors sauf que ses besoins de base se
sont considérablement sophistiqués
depuis un siècle
mais sont probablement des métiers dont
on va dire que ils ont une forme de
résilience
al'inverse on peut désigner des métiers
dont on se dit raisonnablement ils vont
probablement souffrir alors par exemple
dans un monde avec de moins en moins de
pétrole on peut se dire que pilote
d'avion c'est un métier qui finira par
ne plus être extrêmement payant à tous
les sens du terme
même si aujourd'hui si on compterait
bien payé vous avez un certain nombre
d'autres métiers qui à mon avis sont des
métiers qui sont un peu à risque et en
particulier les métiers du tertiaire
alors ça peut paraître étonnant quand on
dit ça parce que souvent on a considéré
qu'une société dématérialisé était une
société dans laquelle tout le monde
travailler dans un bureau
en fait pas du tout une société dans
laquelle tout le monde travaille dans un
bureau et une société de machines on est
occupé à donner les machines ou agents
redonner les pachys plus exactement et
donc les formations qui n'ont pas de
contenu technique opérationnel qui est
et qui permettent uniquement de
travailler dans un bureau sont
probablement le heureusement des
formations qui rendront l'accès au
travail de plus en plus difficile donc
alors c'est déjà le cas en fait quand on
regarde la petite vitesse depuis des
années ou des décennies mais les
formations en psychologie en langue etc
donc je ne dis pas que les disciplines
elle-même sentent inutiles c'est très
bien de parler une langue étrangère
c'est très bien d'avoir des notions
psychologie par contre des gens qui
pourront en faire leur métier principal
dans un monde décroissance énergétique
ça malheureusement
c'est quelque chose qui est qui sera de
plus en plus difficile encore une fois
dans le monde
sobre en énergie dans lequel nous étions
il ya deux siècles les métiers de
services représentaient une très petite
fraction de la population active
l'essentiel de la population active
travailler dans l'agriculture et dans
l'artisanat donc dans une société qui
retournera vers une forme de sobriété
énergétique
il ya probablement
une part croissante des gens qui devront
de nouveau travailler avec leurs mains
il ya un autre une autre catégorie de
métiers qui s'avèrera probablement
pertinente sans qu'on puisse très précis
sur ce que ça veut dire c'est tous les
métiers qui permettront de préserver au
mieux les ressources naturelles
on commence à se rendre compte que ces
ressources naturelles on en a vraiment
besoin pour vivre
un nombre croissant de gens comprennent
que sans avoir des sols cultivables sans
avoir un climat qui n'est pas trop
méchant sans avoir de l'eau sans avoir à
c'est compliqué d'avoir une vie
extrêmement épanouie et donc la
disponibilité des ressources naturelles
est quelque chose qui est central est
donc aujourd'hui on les gère peu parce
qu'on sort du monde a fini dans lequel
en gros chacun et se servir il n'est pas
complètement exclu que dans 1 dans un
monde futur y ait un nombre croissant de
gens qui doivent se préoccuper plus
fortement de préserver ses ressources
de telle sorte que l'on puisse le alors
comment dire équilibré ou amortir le
destin des prendre le destin des hommes
plutôt parce que on n'aura pas de
prendre plus avec ces avec ses
ressources
enfin il ya une dernière recommandation
qu'on pourrait donner à un jeune
aujourd'hui c'est d'essayer de
comprendre au mieux le monde vers lequel
on se dirige alors c'est quelque chose
qui est doublement difficile
d'abord parce qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de mauvaises nouvelles dans le
monde vers lequel on se dirige
il n'y a pas que des choses très très
gai on va dire mais par contre bien
comprendre le monde vers lequel on va
aid nécessairement à se poser les bonnes
questions et n nécessairement à
comprendre où est ce qu'on pourrait être
plus utile ou est ce qu'il y aura des
besoins
donc il ya quelque chose qui me semble
le central également dans cette question
du métier confort d'un voile c'est pas
pour rien que le chiffre a milité pour
que m les enjeux et energy team part il
s'agit bien des ans je ne savais pas une
solution s'agit de comprendre le
problème
d'enseignants supérieure alors
l'enseignement supérieur parce que c'est
la proie la plus facile pour un petit il
tente de 15 personnes comme le d'autres
c'est pas parce que ailleurs rien à
faire c'est juste parce qu'on s'est
attaqué à la j'ai envie de dire la cible
qui était la plus atteignables compte
tenu de nos moyens mais il est
absolument évident que de préparer les
gens qui sont aujourd'hui à l'école ou
en formation ou les adultes qui
reviennent à bien comprendre ce qui nous
attend c'est de toute façon prendre un
ticket pour que l'on fasse une activité
qui soit plus proche de ce qui va
permettre de trouver sa place dans la
société et qui soit
comment dire plus en phase avec ce que
devraient être les besoins de demain
alors après il est question de la parole
scientifique puisqu'on était dans la
définition du problème et de sa prise en
compte dans la planification de la préco
vide alors il ne vous aura pas échappé
que notre ami macron a expliqué qu'il
s'appuyait sur la science pour gérer le
quotidien
alors en fait il s'appuie sur la science
des maladies infectieuses il s'appuie
pas sur la totalité de la science pour
gérer le coc vide parce qu'il ya des
éléments sur lesquels la science
aujourd'hui et huet ou plus exactement
c'est parfaitement sûr que comment dire
il utilise la science pour les éléments
de réponse que ça pourrait lui fournir
je vais être un tout petit peu plus
précis nous allons cette année paire
aller les 10 % de notre pib l'année
prochaine par rapport au pib de l'an
2019 et 2021
je serais très étonnée qu'on y allait en
fait pour quelques années voire forever
on ne reviendra pas 10% du pib français
ça fait 2 120 milliards allait rajouter
encore la moitié de ça pour l'année
d'après les années qui suivent ça fait
300 à 400 milliards
donc monsieur macron a considéré qu' on
pourrait payer 3 ou 400 milliards
réalité des morts dues aux corridas et
que c'était comme ça qu'il écoutait la
science mais il ne sait pas si la
science ne lui aurait pas dit monsieur
macron vous savez si vous voulez faire
mourir le moins de gens possible ces 400
milliards vous les mettez pas du tout
dans la vie de comptes locaux vite donc
on laisse les gens atteints du coc vie
de mourir du colis et enfin ceux qui en
meurent par contre vous mettez ça dans
la préservation d'un avenir moins
violents ce qui évitera des crimes
ce qui évitera du désespoir ce qui
évitera des guerres ce qui évitera de la
famille d'éventuellement de la maladie
d'autres maladies voilà donc la science
ne peut pas éclairer toutes les
décisions dont quand le pouvoir
scientifique entre le pardon quand le
gouvernement dit qu'il s'inspire de la
science en fait ils s'inspirent des
portions qui te connais de la science ou
des portions dans lesquelles il a envie
de taper de la science ne peut pas
s'inspirer de la totalité de la science
ils filent et une décision reste
toujours un arbitrage qui n'est pas un
arbitrage scientifique c'est pas un
arbitre c'est un choix alors est ce que
la parole signifie concernant les
questions énergie climat parce que ça
c'était finalement la question sous
jacente j'imagine qui a été posée est-ce
que ça va monter en puissance après
l'épisode nous sommes en train de vivre
ma réponse très brutale est
malheureusement très paris lui sentent
sait-on aujourd'hui on ne voit pas tout
que le gouvernement ait décidé en bas de
combat de venir demander à l'agent qui
s'occupe d'énergie ou aux gens qui
s'occupent depuis l'un d'eux lui
augmenter son capital de connaissances
histoire qui soit capable de prendre des
décisions plus rationnelle et du reste
il ya eu des questions plus loin
laquelle je répondrais 20 millions pour
le vélo et 7 milliards pour l'avion ça
montre bien que c'est pas complètement
sûr qu'aujourd'hui on aille vraiment
dans la bonne direction
même s'il ya beaucoup plus d'emplois à
la clé dans l'avion aujourd'hui dans le
vélo ya une forme de rationalité dans
cette décision
il n'y a pas toute la rationalité dans
cette équipe donc le est ce que la
presse que la parole scientifique va
être mieux prises en compte non ça
serait le cas si macron avait décidé de
faire un conseil scientifique d'urgence
j'ai envie de dire
pour le conseiller sur les limites
physiques
à la reprise derrière le coc vide voilà
il aurait pu faire ça un éclairage sur
dans quel cadre contraint est-ce que de
kobe tu sais ça c'est avec elle
contrainte je compose donc il aurait pu
demander ça dans un autre domaine il n'a
pas du tout demander et on voit bien que
les premières décisions qui sont prises
ne vont pas du tout dans cette direction
alors le haut conseil
sans trahir de secrets a eu un entretien
hier avec bruno le maire
bon je sais pas ce qui s'est raconté
parce que j'étais pas j'étais
indisponible mais je n'ai pas
connaissance qu'il ya eu un exercice
similaire qui a été organisée avec
l'elysée donc et je n'ai pas non plus
connaissance qu'il y ait un exercice
similaire qui était organisé avec
edouard philippe alors que le conseil
n'est pas formellement du premier
ministre donc il ya là je ne sens pas
aujourd'hui d'appétence ponte années de
la part du gouvernement pour faire ce
genre de choses
à leur décharge je l' ai déjà dit je le
redis c'est pas dans l'urgence qu'on
fait le plan d'urgence et en ce moment
ils gèrent l'urgence en ce moment
navigue à vue et on voit bien je
déconfite jeu des conflits pas et sait
combien de chômeurs supplémentaires ou
un morts évitées en ehpad
aujourd'hui donc ils sont vraiment dans
ce genre d'équations impossible et c'est
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait beaucoup de
place malheureusement pour les ans des
cours après là où on peut commencer à
avoir quelques inquiétudes c'est que mon
sentiment c'est que l'urgence on n'est
pas sortis on commence tout juste à la
fin du mois de juin
quand on va où depuis le mois de juin
enfin je sais pas un moment quelque part
au mois de juin
l'état va arrêter de prendre en charge
vraisemblablement qui vraisemblablement
après tout je ne sais pas finalement
mais bon pari c'est que il va le faire
arrêter de prendre en charge le chômage
partiel des entreprises qui ont dû
confiner dont commandant d'ondés confine
la prise en compte par l'état du para le
tout le monde du chômage partiel
s'arrête à ce moment un nombre très
significatif d'entreprises vont mettre
la clé sous la porte et les gens vont se
retrouver au chômage tout court
une fois que les gens vont être au
chômage tout court je pense que ça va
devenir l'urgence du gouvernement pour
un certain temps alors c'est une urgence
tout à fait légitime
sauf que ça va pas plus leur donner le
temps de réfléchir à l'après demain
parce que déjà ils seront totalement
absorbé par qu'est ce qui m'arrive ce
soir mon ma petite map est strike 2 3
c'est que comme il faut en gros 50 mille
euros de pib pour faire un emploi dans
ce pays
si on perd 200 milliards de pib
eh bien vous voyez ça fait grosso modo 4
millions de chômeurs en plus imaginez
qu'on sera pas très loin
donc ça va faire pas très loin d'un
doublement du taux de chômage
bon donc voilà ça va donner quelques
sueurs froides
encore une fois parfaitement légitime à
notre gouvernement et s'est pas
complètement s'est pas complètement sûr
que dans ce contexte là ils vont trouver
plus de temps pour avoir envie de se
documenter sur ce qui marchera derrière
alors évidemment c'est un drame parce
que ça veut dire qu'ils vont tenter
devant être tenté par don de faire
repartir le système à l'identique
ceux qui sont déjà en train de faire et
si le système ne peut pas repartir à
l'identique
parce que il ya des limites physiques à
ça et bien à ce moment la population
sera désespérés parce que la population
rejettera la faute photos des boucs
émissaires
ça marche pas donc la population
rejettera la faute sur ceux qui essayent
et qu'il n'y arrive pas et comme on
appris à gauche ça marche pas on appris
à droite georges paris a pris au sens ça
marche pas je ne sais pas trop où on ira
prendre la prochaine fois mais il est
vraisemblable que une partie de la
stabilité potentiellement
la france va potentiellement être
l'objet dans les années à venir et en
particulier après 2022 est peut-être en
train déjà de se jouer en ce moment il
ya voilà donc le malheureusement je ne
vois pas de ne voit pas que le
gouvernement soit soit beaucoup plus
réceptif par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en dehors du
gouvernement là il ya un nombre
croissant de gens que je trouve plutôt
réceptifs vous aurez vu passer ces
dernières semaines ces derniers mois
alors j'en avais déjà parlé
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie qui
a dit faux pas repartir comme avant il
ya la commission qui dit alors il dit
tout et son contraire la collection
parce que elle dit faux pas repartir
comme avant mais enfin quelques jours
après avoir dit ça il ya la commissaire
au digital qui a dit surtout surtout
n'arrêtait pas 5 g dépêchez-vous 3 5g
comme si la 5g allait nous sauver du
changement climatique allait créer du
pétrole et créer quoi manger donc et et
calmer les importations jeu sauf erreur
de ma part
l'essentiel des smartphones et des
équipements de réseaux qui sont
nécessaires pour faire la saint-gilles
vont pas venir de france donc le donc la
commission est dense et dans les mêmes
contradictions pour exactement les mêmes
raisons parce qu'elles pensent que le
monde infini peut revenir que le
gouvernement français dans là où les
choses sont plus intéressantes
c'est au niveau d'un certain nombre
d'entreprises vous avez peut-être vu
passer un appel de 90 patrons alors ça
reste un appel il faut voir ce qu'ils
vont faire en vrai mais c'est
intéressant
c'est à dire que l'appel à faire
autrement commence à venir d'un nombre
croissant d'acteurs de la société civile
et c'est plus évidemment il y aura de
gens qui diront il faut le faire et plus
derrière ça sera difficile aux mêmes
une fois qu'on leur proposera des choses
un peu qu'on prête de dire ah non non
non ça j'en veux pas aux noms jeudi
qu'il fallait faire différemment mais si
ça pouvait quand même être pas trop loin
de ce que je fais d'habitude ça c'est
pas une parole
voilà donc le est ce que c'est la parole
scientifique stricto sensu
un peu oui parce que il s'agit bien de
la parole scientifique j'imagine dans
l'esprit de la personne qui a posé la
question sur comprendre le monde et
comprendre comment ils fonctionnent ne
s'agit pas de la parole scientifique
serait ce que j'arrive à faire un
ordinateur plus miniaturisés donc cette
parole scientifique la lp recolle e
doucettement dans le monde économique
si je prends mon propre kara qui comme
chacun sait est pour chacun est toujours
le plus important semble revendiquer de
la parole scientifique je peux me
revendiquer de la parole de la
vulgarisation scientifique si je regarde
le millier de conférences que j'ai fait
pour avoir le prix nobel ça n'a pas
marché donc le millier de confiance que
j'ai fait ces dernières années eh bien
la moitié ont été faites dans le monde
économique
donc le l'endroit qui avait le plus
d'appétence pour comprendre et là où
c'était le plus facile pour répondre
aussi à une question en ce 8 mai sur la
décroissance et sa prise en compte
l'endroit où c'était le plus facile de
dire à la fois des horreurs sur ce qui
nous attend et de prendre le temps
d'expliquer en 2h 3h 4h de quoi il
retourne quand on parle d' énergie et
climat
c'est quand même le monde économique
donc c'est probablement plus de laon et
de gens qui sont habitués à la
contrainte voyez le lancement dans le
monde économique va souffrir donc les
gens vont devoir prendre des décisions
difficiles
il ya plein de chefs d'entreprises qui
vont devoir faire des grandes charrette
et malgré tout le mal qu'on peut penser
d'eux car de temps en temps ils font
penser du mal d'eux pour la majeure
partie d'entre eux et en particulier les
patrons de pme qui croisent leurs
employés tous les jours sur leur lieu de
travail
je peux vous assurer que licencier c'est
vraiment pas un truc qu'on fait quelques
heures moi même je suis patron de pme
si demain matin on devait licencier dix
personnes à 44 je peux vous assurer que
c'est vraiment une décision qui serait
cruel donc la majeure partie des patrons
quand ils licencient
ils font pas ça en disant diplôme
qu'est ce que ça va être rigolo
donc le être dans le monde économique
c'est parfois avoir à prendre des
décisions très très difficile donc vous
avez des gens qui sont épicés regarder
droit dans les yeux des gens avec qui
vous prenez des décisions difficiles pas
coupé j'allais dire de la foule par des
voitures avec chauffeurs et des cabinets
ministériels
donc c'est des gens qui sont conclure
quand même un peu et peut être un peu
dur en à peine un peu plus je pense et
donc leur capacité à absorber de la
formation désagréable c'est comme ça que
j'interprète un petit peu logiquement et
probablement un peu plus élevé mais le
gouvernement ne finira que 20 ne peut
que répondre à des injonctions
extérieures
voilà donc c'est la parole scientifique
elle arrivera au gouvernement quand il
ya un certain nombre de corps constitués
où elle pèsera de tout son poids de
façon vraiment vraiment importante
mon pari depuis le début c'est que
l'endroit où c'est le plus facile de le
faire peser de tout son poids
c'est de ces normes et monde économique
alors après il y avait une question qui
s'y rapproche mais pas tout à fait qui
et comment faire perdurer et progresser
la connaissance dans un monde en
décroissance
l'humanité est elle au pic de ses
connaissances et va peut-être devenir
plus ignorante et bien la réponse
pourrait bien être vous pourquoi ce que
la réponse pourrait bien être oui parce
que pour avoir le temps de mettre tout
un tas de gens dans les labos de
recherche il faut pas qu'elles mêmes
soit occupé à ramasser des patates à
pousser les chèvres dans la montagne
attiser leur pull et à réparer les
portes
donc le la c'est dans les sociétés les
plus énergivores sa part l'un d'entre
vous ont déjà entendu cette affirmation
que vous avez la plus grande part de
gens qui travaillent dans les services
et dans le tertiaire et la recherche
fait partie des gens qui travaillent
dans le service et dans le tertiaire
donc les gens qui ont le temps de se
gratter la tête pour savoir comment
fonctionne le monde ou pour fricoter
pour savoir comment est ce qu'on
pourrait faire tourner plus vite tel
moteur ou
yatuu risée ou je sais pas quoi son par
construction des gens qui n'ont pas
besoin d'être occupés par des tâches
productives immédiate donc plus la
société confie des tâches productives
immédiate à des machines et plus c'est
facile de confier les tâches de
recherche sur le moyen et sur le long
terme à des gens qui travaillent là
dedans
à l'époque où le monde était très
contraint il ya quelques siècles
il y avait très peu de scientifiques et
ses scientifiques étaient par ailleurs
tous entier quand vous regardez les
grands scientifiques il ya quelques
siècles c'est que des nobles
donc c'est des gens qui n'étaient pas
les paysans 1 avec leur haleine est
l'union d'un an c'était que des nobles
c'est à dire des gens qui avaient le
temps de se gratter la tête parce qu' il
n'était pas invité toute la journée à
s'occuper de leur subsistance physique
donc dans un monde qui sera plus
contraints sur l'énergie il est vrai
c'est donc en décroissance il est très
vraisemblable que le capital global de
connaissances ou directement de
connaissances nouvelles va se mettre à
décroître ce qui est une autre manière
de dire ou plus exactement d'alimenter
cette conclusion que certains d'entre
vous ont peut être déjà entendu tenir
qui est que dans un monde en
décroissance la rotation du progresse au
ralenti
la pénétration du progress ralenti c'est
un de mes points de divergence avec les
gens qui pensent qu'on peut faire
pénétrer très très vite des tas
d'innovations techniques dans un monde
en contraction énergétique
moi je pense que non donc c'est une des
raisons qui fait que je ne suis pas
favorable aux moyens qui demande
énormément d'argent
ce qui veut dire énormément de progrès
pour pénétrer par tous je pense que
malheureusement le progrès va se
ralentir dans un monde en contraction
énergétique et qu'il va falloir faire
avec
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça ça ne
veut pas dire que l'on ne puisse rien
faire
ça veut dire par contre qu'on va devoir
faire des choix donc si on n'a pas les
moyens de payer à la fois des chercheurs
pour s'occuper de l'egypte ancienne et
des chercheurs pour s'occuper
d'améliorer la permaculture la question
c'est lesquels on regarde si on n'a pas
les moyens d'avoir à la fois des
chercheurs pour s'occuper de la
meilleure manière de gérer une forêt
dans un monde qui se réchauffe et des
chercheurs pour s'occuper
je ne sais pas quoi de tel ou tel aspect
médical par exemple lesquels on garde
voilà ça va être ça la partie difficile
donc on va dans un monde en décroissance
d'une manière générale et s'appliquera
malheureusement aussi à la recherche
nous allons devoir faire des arbitrages
des choix parce que il y aura des effets
d'éviction
dans un monde en croissance je les dis
souvent je le répète on peut avoir des
moyens nouveaux pour gérer des problèmes
nouveaux et en particulier on peut avoir
des moyens nouveaux pour explorer des
champs nouveaux de la connaissance dans
un monde en décroissance on ne peut pas
faire ça donc dans un monde en
décroissance on devra choisir quels sont
les champs de la connaissance qui nous
paraissent les plus essentiels et
éventuellement dire aux autres bah on
est désolés vous n'avez plus d'utilité
dans ce monde là donc il n'y a pas que
les gens qui fabriquent des avions
malheureusement qui seront
éventuellement sans utilité dans un
monde en contraction énergétique il
pourra aussi parfaitement y avoir des
gens dans le monde de la recherche
la recherche c'est pas du tout quelque
chose qui est uniforme et monolithique
et souvent quand j'entends il faut
préserver la recherche
oui enfin la recherche qui vise à faire
de nous des surhommes et d'étranges
humain c'est une recherche et du reste
la recherche en biologie et de mémoire
celle qui aujourd'hui mobilise le plus
d'argent dans le monde
donc il ya beaucoup plus d'argent qui
est mobilisée pour essayer de croiser
des poissons rouges et l'andouille que
pour essayer de lutter contre le
changement climatique
quand vous regardez j'ai fait un poste
là dessus il ya quelques mois les
articles qui sont publiés dans les
revues scientifiques ce qui touche aux
biotech occupent le haut du pavé de très
très loin la compréhension du monde
physique qui nous entourent c'est un
tout petit segment alors
donc si je prêche pour ma paroisse dans
un monde en contraction on peut se
passer d'une bonne partie des gens qui
cherchent dans les biotech
ça laissera encore suffisamment d'argent
pour les gens qui s'occupent des
contraintes physiques mais c'est c'est
je le redis on va devoir faire des choix
dans ce monde là comme comme dans l'it
alors après il y avait une question qui
est pourquoi ne pas envisager de créer
un parti politique afin de donner plus
de poids à votre vision de la praye
alors le la question du parti politique
est une question que je suis déçu et
désolé je vais pas du tout faire ça avec
de l'anf le mans deux chevilles mais il
ya quelqu'un qui a à la fois penser
qu'il pouvait s'affranchir du parti
politique pour être aux affaires et qui
ensuite a pensé qu'il pouvait
s'affranchir des affres du parti
politique une fois qu'il en a qu créer
un
ça a été de gaulle je vous le rappelle
arrivé au pouvoir par un putsch et
pendant la guerre il pas demandé son
avis a pas eu d'élection et bien après
la guerre il a essayé de se mettre dans
le jeu politique standard et il s'est
fait totalement laminé est en fait il a
fallu que il a fallu le bazar de la
guerre d'algérie pour qu'il revienne au
pouvoir si on n'avait pas eu ce bazar de
la guerre d'algérie ce produit tout sûr
que l'on ait revu
donc le donc la question alors je ne
suis évidemment pas de gaulle le seul
sujet le sujet c'était est ce qu'on peut
penser qu'on est capable de s'affranchir
d'une loi du genre qui est qu un parti
politique c'est en première
approximation une pétaudière
et j'insiste à parti politique c'est une
pétaudière
chaque fois que j'ai fréquenté le monde
politique d'à peu près j'ai vu tous les
rêves deux parties portant un grand
idéal se fracasser sur la réalité qui
est que vous attirez à vous quand vous
commencez à créer un parti politique des
arrivistes des ambitieux des gens qui
sont intéressés par le pouvoir est
absolument pas par le fonds regardez par
exemple ce qui s'est passé avec en
marche
au vu de l'extérieur on aurait pu penser
que c'était un grand élan citoyen etc
porté par un idéal et puis vous regardez
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe parfois
quelques années c'est retombé dans un
jeu extrêmement classique avec as tu
vois tu pas pour moi elle a semblé jeter
je n'exclus pas de ça fonctionne comme
les autres on va dire donc est-ce que
c'est en créant un parti politique qu'on
est le plus audible dans le débat
politique
et bien c'est une question à laquelle ma
réponse évidente départ oui et en tout
cas en ce qui me concerne donc je suis
très flatté par la question qui m'a été
posée puisque ça suppose que le pignon
en actions peut être de quelque utilité
à la collectivité
j'en remercie vraiment lorsque vous
voyez pas mes chevilles la personne qui
a posé cette question mais je ne pense
pas que ce soit en se mettant en
politique au sens classique du terme
c'est à dire en créant un parti qu'on
n'est nécessairement le plus utile ou en
tout cas pas dans le contexte actuel
c'est à dire que dans le contexte actuel
je suis totalement persuadé que je
ferais comme tout le monde c'est à dire
que je me fracasserait sur la réalité du
monde et je ferai une espèce de petit
prony cas comme un certain nombre de
rêveurs l'ont fait avant moi mais à un
moment pour réussir en politique faut
pas être honnête
je suis capable d'être malade est un
[ __ ] probablement diront les
détracteurs mais pas assez en tout cas
passe pas je ne suis pas capable de
composer suffisamment bien avec les
malhonnêtes pour réussir dans ce monde
là parce que il faut en fréquenter c'est
comme ça donc dans le dans la manière
que j'ai choisi d'agir en politique
moi j'ai choisi de créer un une ong
c'est à dire des cheats project et j'ai
choisi de faire exister cette ong au
travers d'un objet qui est la
décarbonation de l'économie alors pour
ma plus grande chance j'ai envie de dire
mais je ne m'en suis rendu compte que
par hasard je suis très très modeste là
dedans je ne me suis rendu compte que
cinq ans probablement après avoir
commencé à faire le bilan carbone que le
carbone c'était l'énergie que l'énergie
c'est lé flux physiques et donc que
céder aux listes hic c'est à dire que
quand on commençait à toucher au carbone
on touchait à absolument tout ce qui
fait la société y compris l'enseignement
y compris les droits sociaux y compris
la géopolitique y compris la splendeur
et la misère des nations y compris les
guerres
donc c'est voilà mais je n'ai compris ça
que très très longtemps après au début
j'avais pas du tout compris c'est quand
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser au climat
mais comme effectivement le carbone donc
l'énergie ceate holistique
ça ouvre la voie à la tentation de se
dire puisque c'est holistique et que
c'est partout donc c'est un merveilleux
objets pour faire un parti un parti et
un programme politique puisque une fois
qu'on a pris position sur ce sujet là
effectivement on a des choses à dire sur
l'enseignement sur la diplomatie sur la
géopolitique sur la construction
européenne et sur la gestion des océans
on peut dire absolument j'ai envie de
dire dans tous les domaines qui sont
couverts par un ministère
peut-être pas la justice mais bon dans
donc ça couvre pas les valeurs
mais à part les valeurs
ça couvre quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de choses dans le monde qui nous entoure
mais je le redis je ne pense pas que ce
soit comme ça que je suis le plus utile
ou en tout cas le plus efficace pour
autant que je considère qu être efficace
c'est amener des choses utiles aux
autres le je pense que je suis très bien
là où je suis
ou en tout cas je suis peut-être pas
très bien mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
saurait faire quelque chose de mieux
donc à travers le chiffre project on
essaye de créer quelque chose qui est un
objet dans le débat politique
car tout les zoos angie militantes sont
dans le débat politique donc le vdf et
aussi dans le débat politique comme la
levée des faits comme l'est la cgt tout
ça c'est des objets qui sont dans le
débat politique
donc le chi project a l'ambition d'être
dans le débat politique et on a même
l'intention d'y être très fortement
puisque comme un certain nombre d'entre
vous le savent
nous avons lancé formellement il ya deux
jours un plan de transformation de
l'économie française
exactement annoncé et donc on a annoncé
qu'on allait se mettre à la planche à
dessin et qu'on allait regarder comment
est ce qu'il faudrait s'y prendre pour
essayer de te dire la trajectoire de
décarbonation qui nous permettra
d'éviter de nous retrouver dans une
cocotte-minute
c'est pourquoi nous sommes
raisonnablement bien parti j'ai posté
pas plus tard que ce matin sur linkedin
un article qui vient d'être publié dans
le plat proceedings of the national
academy of science aux et je vous
préviens que tous ceux qui feront une
blague vaseuse sur mon accent délibéré
pour que tout le monde comprenne se font
tirer l'oreille je donc cet article dit
que avec 5 degrés d'augmentation de la
température planétaire d'ici en 201
d'ici à 2070
eh bien vous auriez entre 1,5 et 3
milliards d'hommes qui se retrouveraient
dans des conditions climatiques où
personne ne vit aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que la température annuelle moyenne des
passerelles un oeuf degrés pour ces gens
là parce qu'avec 4 degrés dose de la
moyenne sur les terres émergées vous
aurez vite en plus en plus 8
et donc ça mettra toute la
quasi-totalité de l'inde et la
quasi-totalité de l'asie du sud est plus
une partie de l'amérique du sud et de
l'afrique
or conditions vivables pour l'humanité
aujourd'hui alors un article similaire
avait déjà été publiée il ya quelques
années
donc vous avez 1,5 à 3 milliards
d'hommes qui se retrouveront dans un
endroit où il sera juste impossible de
vivre
on comprend bien que dans ce genre de
conditions le monde va pas rester très
très stable donc le pour en revenir à ce
que je disais éviter de nous transformer
en cocotte minute me semble être quelque
chose dans ce cas une condition limite
pour que tout ça ne dégénère pas en
boucherie et donc j'estime que dechy
project est à sa place là où il est et
que notre plan de transformation de
l'économie française c'est vraiment ça
qu'on peut faire de plus utile si on
doit être utile à quelque chose et que
si j'étais simple député parce que je ne
peux pas ambitionner grand chose de bien
aussi je pourrais avoir un marocain
pendant deux ans vont très bien à ce
moment je devrai me battre contre bercy
comme tout le monde
premier ministre je ne pense pas qu'on
va offrir et ce ticket je n'ai aucune
valeur marchande
aujourd'hui auprès du grand public il
faut s'appeler faut avoir un nom qui
circule déjà dans les médias pour ça
donc je et puis je crois sûr d'en avoir
envie donc le là où je suis le plus
utile très clairement c'est en
laboratoire d'idées en essayant de
travailler les idées pour les rendre
opérationnels et en essayant de les
faire relayé par des gens qui
influencent fortement la politique est
en fait depuis le début de shit project
a vocation à essayer de s'appuyer sur
des lobbys économiques donc on le
revendique
on l'a suivi il n'y a pas de problème
avec ça parce que c'est des gens alors
on en cherchait d'autres s'il ya des ong
qui nous relayons les radis bien fait en
général les ong environnementales et
monde économique ça sans rien en
essayant de se faire reléguer par
d'autres associations mais quand on dit
qu'on s'inscrit dans un cadre de
décroissance ufc que choisir vous n'êtes
pas trop donc voilà donc on essaye de se
faire relayer la lagon peu et puis de
constituer nos propres forces
il se trouve que les amis du shift les
bénévoles du chiffre ce qu'on appelle
les shifters donc des individus qui
disent
j'aimerais aider petit ours brun vous
aider voilà ça c'est les shifters et les
chiites au j ai bien ce ça fait
aujourd'hui quelques milliers de
personnes cédé 0 il ya quelques années
ça augmente très vite donc c'est en
train de devenir une espèce de partis
politiques quelque part
sauf que c'est un parti politique qui se
construit autour d'un objet autour d'un
programme
donc au lieu de se construire autour
d'un homme comme l'ont trop souvent on
fait les partis émergents
ça se construit autour d'un idéal on va
dire mais qui ne s'est pas incarner dans
des mesures concrètes
nous on essaye de rassembler ces gens là
autour de choses concrètes
justement autour d'objets on va dire
qu'ils sont à peu près correctement
définis et c'est comme ça qu'on essaye
d'avancer
voilà donc donc monde et que je
considère qu'en fait je suis déjà un
objet politique ou un animal politique
pas d'une manière classique mais je le
suis de fait au travers du chili projet
qui veut être dans le débat nourrissant
le débat politique ou qui veut nourrir
le débat politique au travers d'aidés
shifter qui sont déjà quelque part un
embryon de parti au sens d'une
collectivité qui prend un sens à relais
et en essayant d'influencé des lobbys
qui eux mêmes influences le pouvoir en
place
voilà donc c'est pas le jeu électoral
classique encore une fois je
n'ambitionne pas de devenir député je
pense que je m'en garderais dans ce
genre de job que très vite je rongeais
mon frein que les contraintes qui serait
insupportable et que je tiendrais quinze
jours
et puis raconter des salades sur des
dossiers j'ai pas eu le temps de
parcourir je n'ai pas plus envie d'être
ministre exactement pour les mêmes
raisons je pense que je suis très bien
là où je suis en tout cas je ne saurais
rien faire de mieux pour revenir à ce
que je disais tout à l'heure alors on a
déjà prononcé le mot plusieurs fois on y
revient il est écrit en gros dans la
question qui a été posée décroissance en
capital majuscule quand est-ce qu'il va
enfin faire partie des discours
politiques entreprises banques cabinets
de conseil y compris carbone 4 mais je
vais tempéré ça avec une deuxième
question qui a été posée qui est pensez
vous qu'il y est une chance que la
décroissance ça veut dire soit autre
chose qu'une ford emploi est généralisée
et bien malheureusement c'est bien ça le
sujet c'est que quand vous regardez
historiquement les décroissance alors ça
va pas et des dessins pas nécessairement
étaient des foires d'emplois et de
généraliser ça dépend comment ça quand
la décroissance est arrivé parce qu'une
maladie a fait baisser la population
typiquement la grande peste bach ma foi
ça fait pas la guerre
ça fait moins de temps et ça fait de la
décroissance est sûr par contre quand la
décroissance arrive par le biais de
crise économique
et bien malheureusement l'histoire nous
montre que souvent derrière ça se passe
mal et les gens se mettent à se taper
dessus donc le donc la décroissance
oui certes ok je n'ai rien contre elle
vient après baisse et un chemin qui
n'est pas du tout un chemin de roses
et c'est pas du tout un chemin qui est
un chemin sans risque alors quand est ce
que ça va faire partie des discours en
fait ça fait partie d'un certain nombre
de discours déjà quand vous regardez en
creux jeu en ce qui me concerne ça fait
très très longtemps que j'emploie ce mot
alors je ne vais jamais employé dans le
sens de quelque chose qui doit être
désirable gelé toujours employé dans le
sens d'une condition limite à chaque
fois que quelque chose des croix dans
votre entourage c'est rare que ce soit
l'objet principal de votre action par
exemple vous pouvez à vous acceptez que
vos revenus décroissent parce que vous
changez de métier et que vous faites un
métier qui va plus vous plaire
mais ça n'est pas l'objet principal en
général de ce que vous allez faire
vous n'allez pas faire ça pour gagner
moins d'argent vous allez faire ça parce
que vous avez un métier qui fait plus
sens pour vous et s'il se trouve qu'une
des conditions aux limites pour exercer
ce métier c'est de gagner moins d'argent
vous êtes capable de l'accepter
on voit ça même chez carbone 4 puisque
ya chez carbone cap des gens qui nous
ont rejoints kigali aujourd'hui chez
nous moins d'argent que ce qu'ils
gagnent est dans le métier qu'ils
occupaient avant et ou moins d'argent
que ce qu'ils auraient pu espérer
s'il était resté là où il était resté au
bout de quelques années donc ça donc ça
existe déjà dans le comportement d'un
certain nombre d'individus quand on
regarde leur revenu personnel
alors c'est souvent des gens qui restent
au dessus du minimum vital
c'est rare que ça s'applique à des gens
qui descendent en dessous mais quand
même hein c'est quelque chose qui peut
qui peut exister
après en ce qui concerne les entreprises
alors je vais parler de ce que je
connais donc cabinet de conseil
moi j'ai parlé de 44 puisque c'est celui
là que je connais après je vous parlerai
des autres pour ce que j'en connais
carbone 4 depuis très longtemps puisque
jeudi se trouve que j'en suis un des
associés utilisent le mot décroissance
dans l'emile conférence que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure et il ya la moitié donc
je disais qu'ils sont ont été faites
dans milieux économiques
une bonne partie de cette moitié a été
faite au sein d'entreprises qui sont des
clients de carbone 4 donc les clients de
carbone katzav depuis très longtemps que
votre serviteur quand il fait une
intervention il divague ayant les amis
la croissance il va falloir oublier un
moment ou un autre et du reste en europe
on l'a déjà oublié depuis 2008 si on
regarde pour de vrai et là dans les
enseignes et donc ça fait des années que
je tiens ce discours donc le discours il
est tenu après il faut bien voir qu'une
entreprise
elle peut très bien penser qu'elle
n'échappera au sens commun du reste
toute entreprise est une étude est une
activité de conquête c'est quelque part
vous montez une entreprise dit compris
44 c'est une activité de conquête
vous voulez vendre ce que vous faites au
détriment de ce que les gens ont
fabriqué ou détriment de ce que les
autres fabriques que ce soit dans votre
segment où en dehors de votre segment
vous voulez convaincre que ce que vous
faites est utile ou bénéfiques ou et
c'est donc une entreprise c'est une
activité de conquête donc une entreprise
dans mise à jamais sa propre contraction
c'est un truc qui est totalement contre
nature une entreprise elle envisage sa
conquête y compris car le 4 dont 44
envisage de grossir parce que car votre
cape se dit pour le moment on est encore
beaucoup trop petit pour avoir de
l'influencé
là où on pense qu'on devrait en avoir
pour permettre au groupe un cube au
monde où économie mondiale de commencer
à éviter de se prendre les icebergs
alors ça veut pas dire que carbone cap
ne disparaîtra jamais on peut considérer
est tout à fait acceptable que 44 est
une entreprise à auto dissolution
programmée
c'est à dire que le jour où le problème
est derrière nous c'est à dire que le
changement climatique est vaincu eh bien
on dissout car votre 4 et on dissout le
chip project tous les gens qui ont
travaillé pas mettre sur leur cv a
contribué à sauver le monde et donc je
ne suis pas très inquiet je pense qu'ils
retrouveront se trouvant à se recaser
ailleurs avec ce viatique que beaucoup
leur envions donc le mais pour le moment
car 24 est une activité de conquête
comme toute entreprise
encore une fois toute entreprise est une
activité de conquête ça explique
pourquoi soit dit en passant les
entreprises ninove que sous la
contrainte parce que tant que rien de
bien contraindre leurs conquêtes
elles n'ont pas de raison de s'y prendre
autrement donc si vous voulez faire
évoluer une entreprise sur lui taper sur
la tête ça c'est un truc que je dis et
je répète à longueur de journée à chaque
fois que je vois des politiques
n'espérez pas que les entreprises vont
évoluer dans les consorts de grandeur
en tout cas pas les existantes les à
naître qui pourrait être au service
d'activités qui sont compatibles avec le
problème oui les existences qui par
définition ne sont pas compatibles avec
le problème si l'on n'aura pas de
problème n'espérez pas une seconde que
l'on se réorienter à la bonne vitesse
sans qu'on leur tape sur la tête ça
n'existe pas
donc il faut pas avoir peur de
contraindre les entreprises il faut
simplement savoir les contraintes dans
la bonne direction
j'ai publié il ya quelques mois ou
quelques années je ne sais plus
confiants sur les deux dans les échos un
petit papier qui disait on accepte
aujourd'hui que les entreprises fassent
faillite parce qu'elles sont incapables
de concourir à la solidarité nationale
en ce qui concerne les charges sociales
par exemple donc la maladie la
vieillesse en chômage
si vous n'êtes pas capable de concourir
à la solidarité nationale sur la
retraite la maladie et le chômage
on considère que vous pouvez aller au
tapis je ne vois pas de raison qu'une
entreprise qui n'est pas capable de
concourir à la solidarité nationale sur
le plan de l'environnement de puisse
parler au tapis je vois strictement
aucune raison donc on peut très bien
tenir le discours de la décroissance
dans les entreprises simplement c'est de
nul effet parce que une entreprise c'est
une activité de conquête et donc ça
n'accepte pas de décroître c'est un peut
accepter de croître sous conditions ça
peut accepter de ne pas croître très
rare que ça accepte de décroître dans
les banques c'est pareil puisque c'est
des entreprises donc le la bonne la
bonne chose à faire quand on parle de
décroissance c'est de faire comprendre
que toute entreprise va devoir trouver
sa place dans un monde qui lui va être
en décroissance donc lauaki et ça on le
dit depuis le début
à 44 on dit par exemple en ce qui
concerne les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre lens est une marque de
décroissance vous verrez après que ça
rapporte beaucoup de choses une
entreprise qui est résiliente qui s'est
affranchie des risques le climat est une
entreprise qui est capable de conserver
son activité dans un monde où les
émissions baisse de 4% par an et quand
vous regardez bien il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'entreprises qui correspondent à cette
définition
même les jardineries ou les entreprises
qui vendent des chaussettes
sous leur forme actuelle et la deuxième
la deuxième chose c'est une entreprise
qui est capable de résister aux troubles
qui vont être amenées par la partie du
changement climatique on ne saura pas
l'éviter ou en fait que nous n'avons pas
éviter déjà quand vous prenez cette
définition vous rendez compte qu'en fait
le monde va lui-même décroître et que
une entreprise qui survit doit être
capable de tête compatibles avec cette
décroissance c'est compliqué quand vous
êtes à la tête d'une entreprise c'est
compliqué de dire par exemple je garde
des effectifs mais je les diminue un peu
chaque année encore donc je suis dans un
monde en décroissance
donc je garde des effectifs mais je vais
vous payer un peu moins chaque année les
voilà est-ce qu'aujourd'hui les gens
sont prêts à entendre ça bon alors ça
renvoie à une question que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure qui est celle de la
compréhension du contexte de la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes donc
à la racine
la mère de le père de tous les problèmes
comme il faut dire c'est la question de
la compréhension du monde dans lequel on
vit et c'est par ailleurs la question de
l'équité c'est à dire que baisser ma
fiche de paye ici les riches n'abaisse
pas encore plus que moi j'ai pas trop
envie mais mais c'est mais sinon on sait
que c'est compliqué de gérer
concrètement ces sujets là donc un quart
la décroissance nous n'avons aucun
problème à en parler le jeu strictement
aucun moi le premier et quand on dit aux
entreprises
on va vous plonger dans un scénario dans
lequel les émissions baisse de 4% par an
c'est un scénario de décroissance et
donc fait des restitutions clientes dans
un pendant dix ans à des patrons là vous
comprenez c'est un scénario de
décroissance alors les patrons ou
éclatent de rire ou font la gueule
m'engueule le traite de monde oiseaux
affectueusement mais ils comprennent
donc c'est on arrive à en discuter alors
après que extérieurement ils vous disent
j'ai bien compris je vais décroître je
leur ai dit que j'avais la vie c'est une
activité de conquête d'entreprise
est-ce que les autres cabinets de
conseil le fond à ma connaissance non
dis bien à ma connaissance je suis très
prudent mais je pense qu'ils le font pas
pour l'essentiel des gros cabinets de
conseil dans le monde pourquoi parce que
les gros cabinets de conseil dans le
monde sont des cabinets américains donc
pour ne pas les nommer les bcg bay mais
qui de seine c'est des gens qui sont
biberonné à la culture d'un monde infini
parce que leur cerveau limbique vient
des états unis et il n'est de problème
qui ne puisse se résoudre dans la
technologie en général c'est ça mac
intel vient de sortir un rapport à 1,5
degré que j'ai pas encore lu mais enfin
je suis prêt à parier une bouteille de
bon vin et qui veut qu'une fois que je
l'aurai lui je découvrirai que c'est un
monde riche qui vient c'est à dire que
la technologie va tout régler dans un
pib en croissance
donc je pense que c'est ça le discours
qui est tenu aujourd'hui à chela s'est
pas passé grand cabinet et à chaque fois
que j'ai regardé d'à peu près c'est ce
que j ai ce ski j'ai eu je pense que il
dit ils mourront avec le monde qui avait
avec ignorons comment dire il leur
discours restera le même jusqu'à la fin
c'est un peu comme les causes perdues
vous savez je pense que c'est paquebot
là sont pas suffisamment agile et ils
sont ils ont osé ils sont beaucoup trop
construit autour de cette idée là pour
être capable d'en sortir donc eu je
pense qu'ils vont rester sur sept ce
discours là et il va se passer du temps
avant que vous voyez dans ces entités l'
apport dix ans
messieurs les entrepreneurs mais si elle
messieurs les grosses entreprises nous
allons vous aider à ne pas décroître
trop vite dans un monde en contractant
quelques doutes quant au fait que c'est
ça qui va se passer
alors restons dans l'économie et on va
parler de la réindustrialisation donc
question est ce qu une
réindustrialisation de la france est
réaliste possible et souhaitable avec
une logique bas carbone et bien la
réponse courte est oui questions
suivantes
on va quand même des délires bien sûr
que c'est possible si vous remplacez des
machines à fabriquer des meubles par des
artisans qui fabriquent des meubles en
bois brut
c'est une forme de réindustrialisation
puisque vous allez avoir plus d'ouvriers
vous allez avoir donc il faut bien
s'entendre parce qu'on appellerait
industrialisation est-ce que
réindustrialisation c'est augmenter la
production en volume alors là la réponse
est non il ya juste pas photo est-ce que
réindustrialisation c'est augmenter le
nombre de gens qui travaillent dans
l'industrie
la réponse est oui il suffit alors c'est
vite dit comme ça mais il suffit de
baisser la productivité du travail
et comme elle va baisser avec la
contraction énergétique en fait ça ne
pose aucun problème de réindustrialiser
la france au sens de augmenter le nombre
de gens qui vont travailler dans
l'industrie
est-ce que c'est souhaitable la réponse
est oui si vous voulez raccourcir pardon
les chaînes logistiques
il est bien évident que vous allez
devoir fabriquer en france un certain
nombre de choses qui aujourd'hui ne sont
pas fabriqués en france donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut réindustrialiser le pays
est ce que ça veut dire faire partout
des grandes usines plein de béton des
entrepôts ou plaintes etc n'ont pas
nécessairement par contre ça veut dire
ça veut probablement dire dans une
optique de déplacements qui sont moins
faciles parce qu'avec moins de pétrole
vous avez moins de camions qu' il faut
refaire des unités qui sont plus
polyvalente moins productives capable de
traiter un plus grand nombre d'étapes de
transformation et de réparation
dans un rayon géographique limitée mais
ça veut assurément dire que on va
réindustrialiser le pays
il va y avoir un sujet sur les
ressources parce que à l'époque où le
pays était industrialisés on avait des
milles dans le pays maintenant on a plus
donc réindustrialiser le pays quand on
n'a pas son acier pas son charbon
métallurgique et passe en cuivre bon il
va falloir voir avec quoi on arrive à
déstabiliser donc il ya un certain
nombre de choses que l'on va
nécessairement continuer à devoir
importer ce qui veut dire qu'on va
devoir exportés mais il va y avoir
nécessairement me semble-t-il une
fraction croissante de gens qui vont
travailler dans ce qu'on peut appeler
une usine mais c'est pas sûr que dans
cinquante ans ou 100 ans ça ressemblera
à ce qu'ils utilisent aujourd'hui
ainsi le monde n'a pas fait mad max
entre-temps donc le donc la
réindustrialisation me semble quelque
chose qui est parfaitement cohérent avec
le sens de l'histoire
par contre c'est pas sûr que ça veuille
dire qu' il faut faire des grandes
usines de lunettes 3d et de
l'intelligence artificielle
voilà ce qui est probablement ce qui
traîne dans la cervelle d'une partie de
nos dirigeants
quand on leur parle de réindustrialiser
le pays moi je parle de faire des
chaussettes des meubles je parle de
faire chez nous des phases de
transformation de l'agroalimentaire qui
sont plus local par exemple aujourd'hui
si vous faites des yaourts dans des pots
en plastique et bien vous importez le
plastique parce qu'il n'y a pas de
pétrole en france
si vous faites des yaourts dans d'être
dans des pots en verre que vous
conseiller et bien vous pouvez avoir une
industrie qui est plus locale parce que
le verre on peut le faire chez nous avec
du sable et les carbonates qui sont chez
nous pas très branché
donc vous avez des manières de faire qui
sont plus ou moins commode
j'ai envie de dire dans un monde qui
serait industrialise avec une
mondialisation qui baisse la
mondialisation va baisser de toute façon
elle va baisser en volume
je ne sais pas si elle va baisser en
proportion parce qu'il ya des tas de
gens qui vous disent qu'il y avait des
économies très ouverte au début du 20e
siècle
j'ai regardé par contre ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'elle va baisser en volume tout
simplement parce que le porte-conteneurs
qui jauge quatre ou cinq fois le porte
avions nucléaire
et qui est propulsée au pétrole est bien
dans un monde sans pétrole ça marche pas
on va parvenir à la marine à voile pour
transporter les milliers d' équivalent
vingt pieds
saint-vil deal qu'importe comme un cas
porte conteneurs moderne est capable de
transporter donc là des pétroles isation
sera une démondialisation nécessairement
donc ça veut dire que ça va avec une
relocalisation d'une partie de nos
activités productives nécessairement
mais sous une forme qui sera plus serein
et ça ça renvoie également à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure dans ce monde-là
la rotation progrès pénétration du
progrès est plus lente
les objets dureront plus longtemps ce
qui tue d'autres manières de ralentir le
progrès puisque si les objets dure plus
longtemps d'un emploi le progrès pénètre
moins vite
si au lieu de remplacer votre ordinateur
tous les trois en voulant passer tous
les trente ans contre déclin que l'état
augmenté ses performances avec vitesse
voire pas les augmenter de tout ça veut
dire que c'est a ici un ordinateur donc
ça veut dire que vous avez dans ce monde
là un une réindustrialisation qui se
fait aller on va lâcher le bo à base de
los teques ou à base d'une industrie
sobre et et décomplexifier il ya quelque
chose que philippe bihouix si souvent
c'est que aujourd'hui on utilise
essentiellement les éléments sous forme
d'alliages et au mélange c'est évident
qu'une fois que vous avez tout mélanger
vous avez fait une grande sosa vous
n'arrivez pas à retrouver il faut que
j'ai mélangé toutes les couleurs assez
compliqué de retrouver les couleurs
unitaire donc si vous voulez recycler le
verre en verre pas c'est bien de laisser
le vert à part du marron et à part du
rouget à part du bleu et à part du jaune
si vous mélangez tout derrière si
compliqué de tout récupérer en couleurs
primaires va pour les pour les matériaux
ou les métaux c'est exactement pareil
si vous faites des trucs composite
sandwich machin tout mélanger dans tous
les sens
derrière le recyclage est juste
impossible ça veut dire qu'on va
probablement devoir faire des choses
plus simples si on veut avoir une
industrie locale
et une industrie qui soit plus du rhin
donc tout ça tout ça va de pair alors
restons dans l'industrie et parlons
d'allemagne allemagne face à l'allemagne
puissance industrielle et poids lourds
de la chimie est ce réaliste d'envisager
une réindustrialisation de la france
alors je vais pas trop parler de rien du
scd aviation
parce que je viens d'en parler par
contre je vais parler un peu d'allemagne
l'allemagne et makeen comme dirait
l'autre
en ce moment elle le quitte in beaucoup
elle met click in parce que quand vous
regardez le comportement effectif de
l'allemagne depuis allez on va dire dix
ans c'est vraiment moi pour moi et que
les autres aillent se faire [ __ ]
sur le plan du climat
l'allemagne fait à peu près tout ce qui
est allé j'ai envie de dire orthogonale
à ce qui serait pertinent l'allemagne a
effectivement une industrie lourde
qu'elle entend garder donc l entend pas
du tout se réindustrialiser dans le sens
de ce que je viens d'évoquer avec une
industrie qui serait moins lourdes en
fabrique qu'en moins de matériaux de
base parce que je n'ai pas dit une
industrie qui devient un sens pour être
aussi une industrie qui fait moins de
matériaux de base c'est une industrie
qui fabrique moins d'acier - de ciment
moins de plastique parce que fabriquer
ces matériaux de base c'est d'énergie
bord ça revient souvent à réduire d
oxyde par exemple ce qui demande
beaucoup d'énergie
c'est vrai pour la fabrication du ciment
vous devez riz depuis carbonate de
calcium par titre d'oxygène pour faire
du de l'acier vous devez réduire du
minerai de fer et les toutes les
opérations de réduction sont des
opérations très lent de thermique qui
demande beaucoup d'énergie pour les
plastiques vous devez polymérisé c'est
pareil ça vous demande beaucoup
d'énergie donc fabriquer du verbe devait
fondre tout ce qui est j'ai envie de
dire métaux de base s'est très
énergivore donc elle est pas gagné
énormément en efficacité énergétique
pour la nuit des temps donc si vous
voulez baiser beaucoup la consommation
d'énergie dans ces secteurs
vous n'avez que de marges de manoeuvre
vous électrifié avec de l'électricité
nucléaire ou vous réduisez la production
en gros c'est à peu près ça les grandes
marches vous avez un petit petite marge
de manoeuvre avec la biomasse dans les
pays très enfin une grosse marge dans
les pays avec beaucoup de forêts la
suède mais c'est peu accessible pour
l'essentiel des pays densément peuplées
donc que donc l'industrie lourde il faut
la contracter dans un monde qui s'occupe
du client donc l'allemagne dit qu'elle
s'occupe du climat mais n'a absolument
pas l'intention de contracter son
industrie
deuxième sujet la fabrication automobile
l'allemagne fabrique des tanks donc bien
marché donc le elle n'a pas l'intention
de fabriquer des tout petits machins
très sobre alléger donc ça c'est plutôt
une spécificité française en théorie
donc l'allemagne sur le plan de la
construction automobile essaye de faire
perdurer et alors une industrie qui va
dans le mauvais sens et alors il a
trouvé une astuce est dit non non c'est
pas grave on va faire des tanks
électrique quand vous regardez les
émissions de fabrication du tank
électriques voitures plus de batterie
vous êtes à peu près aux émissions de
fonctionnement d'une deux fois pétrole
et qu'ils feraient 500 kg et israël
hybride et bien que les émissions
fabrication ensuite l'allemagne
disposent de centrales à charbon il ne
vous aura pas échappé que la transition
énergétique à l'allemand sait je garde
les centrales à charbon et je bazar de
mai centrale pas carbone donc pour le
climat geof est l'exact inverse de ce qu
il faudrait faire et en fait je fait
l'exact inverse ce qu'il faudrait faire
sur n'importe quel plan sur tous les
plans environnementaux que vous pouvez
imaginer il ya un certain nombre de gens
qui sont tétanisés à l'idée que le
nucléaire pourrait faire tir mobile mais
les mines de lignite ont déjà fait de
charleville les mines de lilith ont
rendu totalement inhabitable entre cent
et deux cents kilomètres carrés de
terrain en allemagne et qui ont été
totalement des caps est totalement
interdit aux écosystèmes décaissés sur
50 à 300 mètres pour alimenter des
monstres de pollution qui bazar des
particules fines par taux de tchernobyl
a déjà eu lieu en allemagne qui
s'appelle le charbon ça a déplacé 80000
personnes tuant 9 850 hockey en commun
ou plus
ça a détruit des villages rendu des
zones inhabitables et là vous avez
l'espoir d'y retourner un jour s'est
détruit détruit il faudra leur donc les
allemands est évidemment leurs centrales
à charbon crash un peu plus de co2 que
les centrales nucléaires leurs centrales
à charbon en bord de rivière sont tout
aussi vulnérables à la sécheresse que
les centrales nucléaires encore de
rigueur donc sur le plan environnemental
vous pouvez regarder tous les
indicateurs que vous voulez qu'ils font
fausse route sur tous les plans en ayant
gardé le charbon à l'élite est en
bagarre dans le nucléaire donc les
allemands vont entraîner l'europe
derrière dans une terrine aux aux
équipements importés solaire et éolien
alors que si on avait fait du nucléaire
national on aurait déjà supprimé à peu
près tout le charbon de rome avec les
mêmes sommes que c'est qu'on a dépensé
un milliard d'euros donc les allemands
sur le plan du climat ils nous
entraînent totalement dans la mauvaise
direction et il faut pas ça que chez eux
qui font ça partout en europe
en essayant d'entraîner le reste de
l'europe alors bon ils ont accueilli 1
millions de syriens ok je veux bien mais
enfin quand on y regarde d'un peu près
je ne sais pas s'ils les ont accueillis
par bonté d'âme ou parce que comme la
population allemande dit il ont du mal à
trouver des gens pour travailler à peu
près je suis pas complètement sur la
motivation était aussi dur que ça
après quand vous regardez ce qui vient
de se passer sur le plan monétaire
l'allemagne la cour constitutionnelle
allemande vient de dire si la banque
centrale ne s'avise de commencer à
racheter des obligations souveraines à
pour que les états puissent maintenir la
tête hors de l'eau et plus encore vu
pour qu'ils puissent décarbonés leurs
économies alors sa narine ou pas
complètement sûr que ce soit une
décision très en phase avec ce qui est
important pour les jeunes
par contre c'est important pour les
vieux et l'allemagne est un pays dieu et
les pays dieu sont des pays rentier donc
c'est un endroit dans lequel les parents
ici d'un modèle c'est beaucoup plus
important de l'avenir alors la mode elle
peut faire partie de l'avenir mais en
gros c'est un pays dans lequel on
privilégie ce qui est favorable au bio
et c'est un peu comme ça que l'allemagne
est géré sur le plan économique
voilà donc être à l'horizon j'ai dit
tout ça
qu'est ce qu'on en tire comme conclusion
pratique on en tire comme conclusion
pratique que je ne crois pas une seconde
on faire parler du climat avec
l'allemagne pas une seconde
donc je ne sais pas si qui que ce soit
les gouvernements regardera la thrombine
enfarinée aujourd'hui mais si oui moi
j'ai un message à leur passé ne comptait
pas une seconde sur l'allemagne pour
faire quoi que ce soit de sérieux dans
le domaine du climat en faire le tour
ce que je crois c'est que les gens qui
sont prédisposés à faire des choses
sérieuses sur le climat c'est les
anglais donc c'est dommage qu'on ait eu
un break site il aurait mieux valu
combien germanique site pour faire une
heure après dans les gens qui sont prêts
à faire des choses sérieuses il ya les
scandinaves les suédois les finlandais
en finlande vous avez le seul parti
alors si c'est pas parce que j'adore le
nucléaire c'est parce que je lui ai tout
petit peu précises et derrière le
nucléaire pour moi est emblématique du
sujet ou si au nom du climat on devient
produc les airs c'est que vraiment on
est capable dans sa tête d'opérer
énormément de changements dans
énormément de secteur donc c'est
peut-être pas le sujet le plus important
de la transition mais par contre c'est
le plus emblématique de l'as de la
tempête de cerveau qu il faut qu'on
arrive à mener pour montrer que on est
capable de changer la hiérarchie et
risques perçus voilà c'est ça en c'est
en cela qu'il est emblématique le
nucléaire c'est pas encore une fois
parce que c'est la plus grande marge de
manoeuvre est que le nucléaire ou pas le
nucléaire ça va nous éviter la poêle à
frire est plus complexe que ça par
contre les gens qui ne sont pas capables
de remettre les problèmes dans l'ordre
c'est à dire de dire hier le nucléaire a
des preuves le plus important je
comprends bien quand je regarde que le
changement climatique peut tuer trois
milliards de personnes que c'est pas
comme ça qu'il faut que je range les
problèmes et je les accepte
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est des gens qui
démontre leur plasticité intellectuelle
et qui démontre la capacité qui l'on a
changé la vision qu'ils ont sur le monde
une fois qu'ils ont une information
supplémentaire et à mettre les problèmes
dans un ordre différent une fois qu'ils
ont une information supplémentaire
c'est ça le point important c'est pas
nucléaire le point important c'est que
ça montre que c'est des gens qui ont une
forte plasticité et qu' il ne s'enferme
pas où il ne s'enferme pas dans des
luttes qui restent les mêmes alors même
qu'on essaye de leur apporter une
information pour leur montrer que le
monde a changé
et qui refuse de prendre cette
information donc le et les allemands
pour moi sont un peu un peu latin donc
retour et les finlandais justement et
comme les suédois sont accessibles à ce
pragmatisme qui est aussi le pragmatisme
anglais qui est qu'une information
supplémentaire est capable de vous faire
mettre les problèmes dans un ordre qui
n'était pas celui d'hier et c'est la vie
c'est comme ça au cours de la vie on est
souvent amené arranger les problèmes
dans un ordre différent
l'ordre dans lequel je range les
problèmes qui me concerne aujourd'hui
n'est pas l'eau pendant lequel je les
range est toujours dans les pays qu'il
faut aller voir pour pour se dé carbonée
après il ya les pays de l'est les pays
de l'est ont un vrai problème ils n'ont
pas envie de dépendants du gaz russe
la pologne c'est bien que son charbon
n'est pas éternel donc c'est peut-être
ces pays hostiles sont accessibles et
tétouan dit en passant c'est souvent des
pays assez pro nucléaires sont
accessibles à ce genre de choses et
enfin à mon avis les pays qui sont
accessibles à ce discours c'est
l'espagne et l'italie qui aujourd'hui
sont une merde noire et qui ont besoin
d'un projet d'avenir et de leurs projets
d'avenir ne peut pas pas être que les
gens vont se saigner pour rembourser la
dette qui a été souscrite par les
épargnants allemands leur projet donc je
pense qu'aujourd'hui le même temps on
considérait que financièrement
là bas il était l'homme malade de
l'europe moi je considère qu'aujourd'hui
sur le plan du climat
alors c'est très désagréable de dire ça
j'ai rien contre les allemands en
dentelle mais je pense que l'état
allemand
aujourd'hui est parti dans le décor et
qu' il est urgent de faire en sorte
qu'il en aille autrement
alors ça peut vouloir dire comme aux
états unis où il introduit aussi qui
part dans le décor que c'est au niveau
des adultes
c'est au niveau des entreprises c'est au
niveau des collectivités locales faut
essayer d'avancer dans la bonne
direction mais probablement que c'est
une chose aussi très clairement parce
qu'il s'agit pas de se taper dessus avec
les allemands par contre s'ils étaient
parce que ce qui me paraît évident on
sait que la manière de prendre le
problème en europe
aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas commencer
par discuter avec les allemands de ce
genre de sujet il faut faire le
coalition extra allemande et c'est une
fois que cette coalition sera en fait
qu'à ce moment il faut discuter avec les
allemands
qui sont quand même il faut le dire
aujourd'hui en europe quand même un peu
dans une logique de rapport de force
donc tant qu'on n'arrive pas à peser de
son poids face à eux et bien un père
l'on perd le rapport de forces est
pareil on la france s'est un peu trop
souvent me semble-t-il mise en europe
dans une position de ba ty avance à
double titre d'abord parce que la france
considère que d'aller plaider sa cause
au sein de l'europe c'est quelque chose
qu'il n'est pas utile c'est là qu'on
envoie donc ma classe et à l'europe en
général qu'il ya quelques exceptions
mais en règle générale c'est ce qu'on
fait et c'est la représentation
française à la auprès de la commission
et les plus petites numériquement que la
représentation du seul land de bavière
il ya quelques années je passe donc
c'est une façon de dire que l'on
considère que comme on l est plus
intelligent du monde probablement
l'europe s'alignera sur l'eau et
particuliers si on n'existe pas si on
montre pas si on n'est pas persuasif si
on n'investit pas des moyens là tant il
se passe rien donc le la france
aujourd'hui n'ose pas tenir tête à
l'allemagne n'ose pas lui dire écoute et
vous êtes gentil mais la face à raul
bien n'est pas d'accord avec vous et on
le dit et bien je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on est un peu trop timorés dans cette
histoire alors si on a très envie de
rester timoré pour d'autres raisons à ce
moment a même discuté avec d'autres et
intelligente à faire sur le climat mais
pas avec les allemands c'est une cause
perdue me semble-t-il
aujourd'hui alors après on me demande de
préciser une remarque que j'avais faite
le 19 avril c'est précis concernant la
migration des villes vers les campagnes
comme partie de la solution de
décarbonation on serait plutôt tenté de
dire le contraire et que toute
concentration plus de monde en moins de
places génère des économies d'échelle
transporte du cours chauffage partagés
etc
alors oui c'est absolument certain que
peuvent qui concerne le chauffage et les
experts du quotidien la densité urbaine
diminue les besoins
un premier communiqué un premier élément
qui est géométriques c'est que quand
vous habitez en appartement en ville là
est bien le rapport surface en contact
avec l'extérieur sur volume chauffer de
l'appartement diminue à mesure que vous
êtes dans un immeuble de plus en plus
gros donc de la physique tout bête parce
que la déperdition est proportionnel
surfaces en contact avec l'extérieur de
la géométrie tout bête vous dis que
quand vous habitez dans des logements
collectifs
vous n'êtes pas reconstruction dans un
type de logement qui est moins qui a
moins de déperdition que le logement
individuel en ce qui concerne le
chauffage et tu restes la climatisation
s'il ya un confort d'été donc là c'est
tout à fait vrai la deuxième chose qui
est tout à fait vrai c'est que en ville
vous pouvez avoir accès à des réseaux de
chaleur chauffer au bois
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est par
exemple en suède est extrêmement répandu
après ça dépend de la quantité de terre
brûlée dans un pays donc en belgique ça
marchait bien mais c'est quelque chose
qui peut vous être accessible
la troisième chose absolument évident tu
sais qu'en ville quasi totalité services
qui sont indispensables au quotidien
toutes ses cibles à qui donc vous pouvez
à paris par exemple le ménage sur deux
n'a pas de voiture ça va être augmenté
récemment vous pouvez tout faire à pied
et si vous habitez dans le centre de
toulouse de bordeaux ou de grenoble vous
pouvez tout faire à pied
vous avez des épiceries qui sont
accessibles à pied tout faire par contre
il ya d'autres effets qui vous ne voyez
pas mais qui augmente
l'empreinte quand vous êtes en ville
alors le premier effet que vous ne voyez
pas mais qui augmente l'empreinte quand
vous êtes en ville c'est que enfile le
foncier est plus cher le foncier est
plus cher parce que la ville est un lieu
d'échangé que les charges de la valeur
mais j'y reviendrai après parce que
c'est ça envoie ou parce que j'avais
évoqué sur pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut
dégonfler lille dans un contexte de
décarbonation donc en vidant général
vous gagnez plus d'argent que vendeur de
la ville enfin donc en france et donc
vous allez acheter plus de choses parce
que quand vous gagnez de l'argent vous
dépensez donc il ya un premier effet lié
à la ville qui est qu'en général la
consommation des individus est plus
élevé et donc la part de leur empreinte
carbone qui est lié à ce qui se fabrique
ailleurs et à ceux qui s'achemine
jusqu'à la ville augmente
la deuxième chose c'est que en ville et
on l'a bien vu avec le confinement là
maintenant j'ai pas besoin de faire la
démonstration on étouffe entre
guillemets donc les gens qui habitent en
ville ils n'ont pas envie qui restait en
permanence et on le voit bien là la
quasi totalité des gens qui ont été
confinés en ville dans le béton
idéalement dans un appartement et pour
une bonne partie d'entre sans balcon et
sans terrasse eh bien ils n'ont pas du
tout envie d'y rester en permanence
donc quand vous êtes en vie dès que vous
avez les moyens et bien vous n'avez plus
envie que les autres de prendre votre
voiture et de prendre l'avion pour aller
voir ailleurs le temps qui fait alors
que les gens qui n'habitent pas envie
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet barbecue
et bien ils sont plus stables pendant
les week-ends et pendant les vacances
ils ont la bougeotte ligne en moins
envie d'aller voir ailleurs le campion
le troisième élément c'est que en ville
vous augmentez les flux logistiques qui
sont nécessaires à votre vie parce que
en ville vous êtes plus loin notamment
de l'agriculture et de la production
d'un certain nombre de choses qui vous
sont plus accessibles quand vous êtes en
de la ville et notamment de
l'agriculture le la ville de produits
passant sa propre nourriture quand vous
êtes en ville toute la nourriture est
donc acheminés et en france je le
rappelle un camion sur trois transporte
quelque chose qui se mange donc une
bonne partie du transport routier
alimente les urbains
quand vous n'êtes pas en ville et bien
vous pouvez avoir accès plus facilement
aux marchés du coin où le producteur du
coin vous amène les eaux du coin les
fromages du coin les points hauts du
point les pattes du coin le poisson du
coin si vous êtes en campagne et à ce
moment tout ça aura fait beaucoup moins
de kilomètres par rapport à la ville
donc vous avez une dépendance à la
logistique longue en ville à la fois à
travers vos achats qui sont plus
importants qu'ailleurs est à la fois à
travers votre nourriture qui est plus
importante
donc quand vous comme par ailleurs
l'empreinte carbone est essentiellement
pensionnés le revenu parce que vous
dépensez ce que vous gagnez et que les
revenus des urbains à sont plus élevés
que les revenus des données urbain liens
et bien il se trouvait l'empreinte
carbone des urbains et en règle générale
supérieure à ce qu'elle est ailleurs on
pas que ce soit le cas il faudrait que
l'argent que vous gagnez vous ne le
dépensier pas et vous n'en fassiez rien
en termes d'épargné qui va aller
financer les émissions des autres
par exemple vous pouvez brûler comme a
fait 15 bourg donc si vous gagnez plus
d'argent et qu'une partie de cet argent
vous le brûler alors vous avez pas
devoir faire feu de cheminée à paris
dont je préfère calciné volée et bien à
ce moment oui la ville c'est très bien
mais sinon ça marche pas parce que vous
avez tous les effets que je viens
d'évoquer qui font que c'est plus
compliqué que l'idée qu'on sait par
contre ce qui est un véritable élément
de gains c'est l'accessibilité des
services et la densité de l'habitation
donc les deux éléments que donc le
meilleur des mondes j'ai envie de dire
c'est d'avoir des petites villes partout
et des villages danse et du reste quand
vous regardez les coeurs de ville et les
coeurs de villages de l'ancien temps
même un village qui faisait quelques
centaines d'habitants et bien les gens
étaient entassés les uns sur les autres
parce que c'est comme ça que vous étiez
en interaction maximale avec vos
semblables et que tous les services
étaient accessibles et que par ailleurs
on minimisait la dépense de chauffage
donc en fait la densité oui mais vous
n'avez pas besoin de villa eng 2
millions d'habitants
on va voir de la densité vous pouvez
très bien avoir de l'intensité dans une
ville de 5000 habitants
sanogo strictement aucun problème
donc en fait si vous voulez avoir le
bénéfice de la densité votre problème
s'appelle le pavillon que vous soyez en
grosse ville ou en petite ville c'est
pas ça le sujet le sujet c'est de ne pas
habiter dans une maison individuelle
c'est d'habiter dans du collectif vous
allez dire à c'est ennuyeux parce que
les gens ont justement envie d'habiter
dans une maison individuelle avec un
bout de jardin mais oui absolument mais
le mais c'est bien la question de la
compacité de l'habitat et de
l'accessibilité des services qui permet
de gagner sur ses terres après il ya la
question de la taille de la ville
alors là j'y reviens migration des
villes vers les campagnes donc ce que
j'ai pour être précis ce que j'ai
évoqués la dernière fois c'est pas la
migration des villes vers les campagnes
c'est le fait de faire dégonfler les
grosses villes mais ça peut très bien
être faire migrer une partie des gens
des grosses villas père des petites
villes vous avez beaucoup de petites
villes qui se sont vidés ces dernières
années vous avez vous passé dans
certaines petites villes en dix petites
villes ces cinq à vingt mille habitants
vous avez n'ai pas d'eau avant
absolument partout donc vous pouvez très
bien
6 et 7 6 s'est avancé que ces villes et
si séville et d'employeurs maîtres du
monde
d'après la question c'est qu'est ce que
vous voulez qu'ils vont la c1 le sujet
de l'activité d'hébergement j'ai envie
de dire vous pouvez avoir un transfert
qui va dans l'autre sens
alors pourquoi ce qu'il faut faire
dégonfler les grosses villes parce que
votre premier besoin c'est de manger à
manger et boire deux premiers besoins et
dans un monde en des flux énergétiques
voulait dit tout à l'heure le pétrole
sert à faire avancer des camions et bien
dans un monde en décrue énergétique
une des choses qui va être de plus en
plus difficile c'est d'assurer des flux
logistiques long or si vous ne pouvez
pas assurer des flux logistiques l'on
vous commencez à avoir une contrainte
sur l'alimentation des grandes villes
pourquoi
alors je le redis à l'époque où vous
n'aviez pas de transport comme une ville
pouvait être bris parce qu'encore une
fois il fallait que les habitants soient
nourris une ville pouvait être nourrie
par le surplus agricoles parce qu'il
fallait que les agriculteurs se nourrit
semaine un les paysans seulement une
semaine donc une ville pouvait être
nourrie par le surplus agricoles dégagé
par un disque dont le rayon et des
quelques jours de marche à pied jusqu'à
la ville encore pourquoi quelques jours
parce que à l'époque où les denrées
peuvent pas se conserver facilement
c'est le temps que en été paul bulcke
pourrissent pas c'est le temps que en
hiver sous la pluie les trucs sabine pas
posé voilà quelques jours de quelques
jours de marche à pied
jour 3 jours c'est la raison pour
laquelle à l'époque de l'astérix le
gaulois du test les 10000 habitants donc
dit l'habitant aujourd'hui c'est une
toute petite ville et c'est la capitale
de la gaule les villes qui étaient
beaucoup plus grosse à l'époque
typiquement romains étaient des villans
bordeaux et donc en bordeaux vous
pouviez importer des céréales par bateau
et c'est notamment roma a servi l'egypte
pour ça et dont vous pouvez voir une
ville beaucoup plus importante
et parce qu'elle était placée à un
endroit où il y avait une voie de
communication qui n'était pas la marche
à pied et dès que vous aviez une ville
dans l'intérieur des terres où là vous
aviez un peu de bateaux ce cas du test
vous aviez un peu de bateaux et de la de
la marche à pied donc le il fallait
acheminés sur place de quoi construire
les habitations c'est pareil dubois des
pierres dans ma foi il n'est pas en
faire venir tant que ça quand vous aviez
pas les camions donc aujourd'hui en fait
ce qui permet de faire vivre la ville
c'est les transports et donc dans un
monde aux transports très abondants vous
pouvez faire des grosses villes
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
quand vous regardez donc il ya des
enregistrements vidéo de conférences
auxquelles je peux vous renvoyez
notamment celles à 150 que j'ai fait il
ya pas très longtemps à l'époque on
avait encore le droit rassemblé plus de
10 personnes dans un amphi
il ya une éternité donc eh bien je
montre des tables courbe des tas de
régression que j'ai fait mais pas
longtemps qui montre que la part des
gens qui habitent en ville augmente avec
les émissions de co2 par personne et
donc notamment la consommation de
pétrole par personne donc pour avoir
beaucoup de gens qui habitent en ville
et notamment en grandes villes il faut
avoir beaucoup de transport et donc des
grosses émissions de co2 par personne ne
dit rien on peut tout électrifié pas sûr
quand on regarde le rythme auquel ça
peut se faire
vous allez pas mettre un train qui part
de chaque champ pour arriver dans chaque
village ou dans chaque ville et vous
allez pas mettre une batterie dans
chaque camion pour faire 500 bornes pour
aller du chant asperges jusqu'à chaque
ville un jeu ça marchera pas donc dans
un monde où il ya beaucoup moins de
pétrole
et bien comme votre premier besoin c'est
de manger il va falloir vous rapprocher
de là où ça pousse et donc vous
rapprocher de là où ça pousse c'est la
disparition des grandes villes donc
c'est ça que j'ai essayé d'expliquer la
dernière fois c'est que la première
contrainte est temps de manger
nous allons avoir besoin dans un monde
aux transports qui décroissent de faire
décroître les endroits qui sont très
loin dit devant des traits des flux très
très long pour être alimenté
voilà c'est ça le point et ça demande
aussi doit dit en passant dé fut très
long pour que la construction et donc la
réparation des immeubles puisse prendre
place pour que l'événement puisse être
acheminée parce que les vêtements des
parisiens c'est quoi ces du coton c'est
à dire des trucs qui ont poussé à des
milliers de kilomètres c'est du pétrole
pour toutes les fibres synthétiques
c'est à dire des choses qui ont été
extraites à des milliers de kilomètres
et c'est un peu de la halle et le laos à
poussan france mais enfin pour le moment
[Musique]
voilà et c'est de la laine et la laine
on en fait quasiment plus en france
maintenant et bien d'autres zélande
d'australie et chez paou donc
aujourd'hui c'est des flux logistiques
extrêmement l'eau qui permettent de
faire vivre les villes et je le redis
dans un monde qui va devoir se
démondialiser et avec des flux
logistiques qui vont devoir se
raccourcir
c'est évident que les villes on va
pouvoir rester comme elles sont sans
souffrir alors allez une petite question
à laquelle j'ai déjà répondu en creux 20
millions pour un plan vélo 7 milliards
pour la france 1 milliard pour renault
est ce que la messe est dite
alors les milliards aujourd'hui vont je
l'avais déjà dit donc je répète vont là
où sont les emplois sauvés il ya peu
d'emplois sauvés dans le vélo il ya peu
de gens qui travaillent dans la
réparation de vélos dans la fabrication
de vélos il ya aujourd'hui c'est des
milliards qui vont pour essayer
désespérément de par avoir des millions
de chômeurs derrière et le plan n'est
pas prêt pour que en l'espace de six
mois ou d'un an les gens qui fabriquait
des voitures fabriquées vélo voilà donc
on peut mettre les milliards dans le
froid est-ce que la messe est dite pas
nécessairement la première messe oui
mais je l'avais comme comme disait le
2-1 dans la série
je l'avais prédit alors lors du premier
facebook la règle je vous le dis les
milliards iront là où là où dans les
activités existantes c'est exactement ce
qui se passe et ce avec un empattement
la messe n'est pas dite pour l'après
alors le la mais c'est tellement petit
pour l' après que je le redis dechy
project va présenter fin du printemps
début de l'été un plan pour transformer
l'économie française donc c'est bien
comprendre que la messe n'est pas dite
parce que si on pensait qu'elle était
totalement dit n'en ferais pas ça et je
crois qu'il va y avoir une audience qui
va croître au moment où on se rendra
compte que malgré cette 1ère bac 2
milliards
en ce qui concerne l'économie
malheureusement sa myopie donc parce que
il ya des contraintes autres notamment
pétrolières qui vont empêcher que ça la
situation se rétablisse rapidement à ce
moment là il pourra y avoir
éventuellement des milliards pour autre
chose
il est évident que ce serait beaucoup
mieux d'avoir sans un petit calcul tient
que j'ai fait il ya pas longtemps
vous m'avez déjà entendu dire un certain
nombre d'entre vous que 120 milliards
c'était le la totalité de l'argent que
le contribuable français à les mettre
dans les panneaux solaires et les
éoliennes qui ont été installés autorisé
à fin 2018 donc si vous prenez la
totalité des éoliennes et des panneaux
solaires installés autorisé à fin 2010 8
ça va coûter en impôts aux français 120
milliards c'est la différence entre le
tarif garanti et le prix de marché que
l'état paye qui a aidé f qui est
l'opérateur pour ça au producteur
d'électricité éolienne et solaire sont à
millas qui ne vont servir à peu près à
rien dans notre pays à d'autres pays où
je serai très bien faire ça probablement
mais en ce qui concerne la france assez
peu près que des impôts mika avec ses
120 milliards j'aurais été capable de
mettre une piste cyclable le long de
tout km de routes en france 120
milliards donc on a un million de
kilomètres de routes en france le coût
d'une piste cyclable en bande c
paraissait 80000 euros du kilomètre en
autonome
si vous la faites femmes scratch et
300000 euros du kilomètre alors je vous
fais une cote mal taillée pour
l'ensemble de la du pays je vous le fais
à 100 et bien ça veut dire qu avec 120
milliards je fais 1,2 million de
kilomètres de pistes cyclables donc j'ai
le moyen de vous faire aller de
dunkerque abandon en vélo en site propre
sans croiser leurs fins en cohabiter
avec la moindre voiture d'un bout à
l'autre de la france
on en rit avec le même argent avec le
même argent aujourd'hui on sera capable
de circuler partout en vélo on voit
sécurisé et bien évidemment l'usagé du
vélo pourraient considérablement se
développer
donc est ce que ça veut dire que
la messe est dite à très court terme oui
est ce que ça veut dire que la messe est
dite et qu'il faut arrêter de militer
pour un plan b long qui ressemble à
quelque chose et non pas une aumône
comme aujourd'hui n'ont rien qu'un
ouvrage pour faire passer une piste
cyclable par exemple sous une voie
ferrée ou sous une route
ces quelques millions oui donc on a de
quoi remettre tout le btp au travail
quasiment tout le btp au travail
essentiellement sur un plan vélo
d'accord donc la fntp j'espère qu'ils
vont demander à ce que la façon de les
sauver ça soit pas de rajouter des voies
routières voire de les entretenir
telles qu'elles sont mais bien de les
transporter partout et tout le temps
pour que l'on puisse circuler à vélo
de plus en plus donc mais à très court
terme je le redis c'était évident que
c'était ça que l'espace et qu'on avait
essayé de sauver des emplois qui qui
existait peut-on faire travailler
durablement 30 millions de personnes
dans un pays visant la sobriété et la
décroissance
eh bien il vaut mieux problème la vraie
question en fait c'est par est-ce qu'on
peut les faire travailler c est ce que
comment est ce que l'on va faire
accepter que le travail rapporte moins
parce que c'est quoi la croissance si je
reprends le si je reprends le la
définition exactement le câble car la
technique c'est la croissance du pib
c'est quoi le pib stricto sensu
c'est la totalité des revenus des agents
économiques du pays
c'est sur le pib donc le pays baissé
l'empilement des salaires et des rentes
que gagnent les agents économiques d'un
pays alors les salaires vous comprenez
bien ce que c'est c'est ce que gagnent
tous les gens qui ont une fiche de paye
les rendent c'est quoi ces les résultats
des entreprises les loyers le produit du
capital vous pouvez très bien dire bon
dans un premier temps dont les
capitalistes bon très bien alors et un
arbitrage
parce que si vous voulez notamment les
supprimer ça s'appelle le régime
communiste
c'est ce qui est une option mais ça a
des inconvénients
moi je suis pas très pressé que mon
vendeur de carottes bio au marché
devienne un fonctionnaire c'est très
bien que ce soit 1,5 capitaliste qui en
l'occurrence gagnent le smic ou à peu
près
que je trouve très sympathique et qui a
pas fait ça pour s'enrichir sur le dos
du bon peuple et c'est un caissier tout
à fait capitaliste car votre carton et
des sales capitalistes puisqu'on est
copropriétaire de l'entreprise avec mes
associés tous les capitalistes sont pas
nécessairement des gens qui veulent le
malheur du coq si on supprime la
totalité des capitalistes pas par
exemple moi je deviens fonctionnaires je
vous pose la question je pose la
question est-ce que vous pensez que je
ferais mieux mon travail si j étais au
service de l'état si tu étais un
fonctionnaire je peux vous dire tout de
suite non à l'ombre d'un doute parce que
si j'ai des fonctionnaires le seraient
aux ordres du politique et donc pour la
destruction donc le donc ça n'a pas que
des inconvénients et les avantages
pardon clé des fonctionnaires partent
par contre ce que vous pouvez évidemment
discuter c'est de l'arbitrage entre la
rentrée et le salaire peut très bien
considérer qu'aujourd'hui il ya tout un
tas de domaines dans lequel la rampe est
excessive et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec cette prise de position
est que on peut la baisser au profit des
salaires il n'empêche que si dans ce
pays
la rente est une partie est le salaire
une autre partir je vais vous faire une
règle de trois admettons que dans ce
pays la rendre ce soit 20 à 30% des
revenus j'ai aucune idée et remet en
tout cas c'est à 80 et les salaires 70
80 si vous divisez le pib par quatre ce
qui en première approximation ce que
vous allez obtenir si vous divisez la
quantité d'énergie pour machines la
quantité de croquettes pour machines par
quatre et bien vous allez diviser les
revenus par quatre et vous voyez bien
qu'il suffit pas de supprimer les rentes
du capital pour que les salariés gardent
leurs revenus intacte on peut le dire au
sein des salaires on peut supprimer les
banquiers millionnaire ok je suis tout à
fait d'accord si supprimant les
banquiers millionnaire leur utilité
sociale n'est pas du tout à la hauteur
de la rue mais c'est enfin voila je vous
pouvez gratter un peu partout vous vous
rendrez compte que au fond dans un monde
qui va entrer en décroissance
malheureusement les classes moyennes
vont devoir accepter que le revenu des
croise aussi donc ça va être ça le vrai
problème c'est faire accepter aux gens
qui aujourd'hui considèrent qu' ils sont
à l'arrêt ce que est ce qu'il est
légitime aujourd'hui de dire aux
infirmières votre revenu va décroître
dans un monde en décroissance est-ce que
bon
est-ce qu'il est léger car vous allez
dire à la veille en a plein d'autres qui
doivent passer avant dont les banquiers
millionnaire ok encore contacter les
banquiers millionnaire les consultants
trop pays à 44 hockey mais quand vous
regardez bien les ordres de vendeurs
vous vous rendrez compte que
malheureusement ça va pas suffire mais
malheureusement tout le monde va devoir
y passer
donc la vraie question sur est ce qu'on
arrive à conserver un emploi pour chacun
dans une société en décroissance c'est
comment est ce qu'on fait accepter
quelles sont les contreparties qu'on
propose pour que les revenus baissent
comment est ce qu'on y arrive alors il
ya quelques moyens un premier moyen
c'est que le coût de l'immobilier
baissent si le coût de l'immobilier
baissent c'est quand même 30 % de ce que
les gens dépensent peu ou prou bassa'a
laisse une sacrée marge de manoeuvre
pour que les revenus diminuent sans que
ce soit trop douloureux si les gens se
font leur propre potager bien vous avez
une partie de leurs dépenses
alimentaires qui peuvent être donc il ya
un mais le propre potager vous le ferez
pas en ville confère la remarque j'ai
fait tout à l'heure sur le fait que
rester dans la ville par contre avec des
revenus qui baissent vont se déplacera
plus comme aujourd'hui donc c'est aussi
mais ça renvoie au fait que la société
en contraction est une société moins de
mobiles aujourd'hui voilà mais le vrai
véritable enjeu c'est comment est ce
qu'on fait en sorte que les gens
regardent l'avenir avec une forme de
confiance et d'espoir ou de fatalisme la
limite je t'ai pas dans un monde dans
lequel les revenus l'ess et le c'est la
raison pour laquelle le pouvoir
politique a une sainte horreur de
s'attaquer à ce problème c'est que lui
parler de ça vous lui parlez de
voldemort c'est pareil c'est vraiment le
truc qui vous glacent d'effroi
vous vouliez pas comment vous allez en
sortir dans ce genre de monde alors
o'shea project on n'a peur de rien on va
quand même essayer de commencer à
attaquer doucement cette question
puisque dans notre plan de
transformation de l'économie française
on ne présuppose rat pack est de la
croissance donc nous on va pas tabler
sur le fait qu'il y aura plus d'argent
pour tout le monde et que youplaboum du
coup ça sera que du bonheur maintenant
on va vraiment réfléchir à la manière de
gérer une forme de décroissance au sens
où on prendra pas cela comme acquis par
contre encore une fois dans un premier
temps il reste tout un tas de marges qui
sont les inégalités salariales
l'arbitrage entre les rentes et le
salariat la question du foncier et la
question du coût de l'emplacement de là
où sont les gens une bonne manière de
gérer le problème alors peut-être que
certains qui me regardent vont sauter en
l'air c'est l'arbitrage générationnel au
moment où les gens partent à la retraite
s'ils voulaient remplacer par des gens
qui gagnent moins
vous avez résolu votre problème du côté
des entreprises à ce moment il faut
juste faire en sorte que les gens qui
rentrent au cours de leur carrière dans
l'entreprise gagne moins que les gens
qui en sortent non gagnés au cours de
leur carrière dans l'entreprise
il faut que les revenus cumulés baisse
du temps mais comme on vit en france
dans un régime de retraite paraît
parfois qu'on est un régime de retraite
par répartition
si vous baissez les revenus des actifs
ça veut dire que vous baisser les
pensions versées aux retraités et donc
les retraités vont gagner moins d'argent
et donc ça veut dire que peut-être il ya
aussi un sujet qui va revenir sur la
table qui est est-ce qu'on va devoir
récupérer ses vieux parents à la maison
parce qu'ils n'ont plus les moyens
d'être financièrement autonome
voilà c'est ce qui je vous le rappelle a
été la manière dont on a géré les
générations pendant très très longtemps
pendant très très longtemps il n'y avait
pas les moyens financiers pour les
familles d'être éclaté avec les enfants
habitant ici les parents l'aele et quant
à rend encore ailleurs vous aviez à
domicile pour tout le monde vous deviez
vous palucher votre belle mère toute la
journée
voilà ça faisait partie des
inconvénients de la faire mais où votre
beau père à tous les programmes et
sexiste mais par contre où votre
beau-frère offrir de cabu mais par
contre
vous aviez à une charge locative qui
était nécessairement plus faible puisque
vous aviez un seul grand logement pour
plusieurs personnes
et donc il y avait des effets des
économies d'échelle aujourd'hui on a
plusieurs logements pour plusieurs
personnes
et puis quand les gens sont très vieux
le logement est médicalisé donc ils
coûtent très cher collectivement et puis
en plus si les gens ont la mauvaise idée
d'y mourir vous faites un procès à
l'époque parce qu'évidemment il sort mal
occupé d'eux donc le jeu c'est pas du
tout une blague un jeu il ya un d-pad à
côté de chez moi et c'est exactement ce
qui est enfin se passer en ce moment
donc le la manière de mon avis l'une des
manières douces de gérer le problème
c'est de 30 de troquer on va dire des
gens qui sortent par des gens qui
rentrent qui font pas nécessairement le
même métier donc si à chaque fois que
vous avez un employé de bureau qui sort
dans un siège de grandes entreprises qui
est un peu moins pertinente et qui est
remplacé par quelqu'un qui va aider un
fermier fabriquer les yaourts le salaire
ne sera pas le même par contre vous
allez avoir un sujet sur l'équilibré des
régimes de retraite
vous allez avoir un sujet et puis vous
allez également avoir un sujet sur la
protection sociale puisque c'est aussi
les charges sociales qui alimentent le
système de soins et le fameux système
hospitalier qui en ce moment tout le
monde le dit devrait être valorisée donc
vous avez un problème de passes
communiquant sur le système par
répartition dans ce pays c'est pas
nécessairement sur les agents productif
que le problème sera le plus fort il
sera au niveau des grands équilibres des
grands équilibres dans le pays voilà
donc le problème est pas simple je le
dis en toute en toute modestie il faut
pas en vouloir
facile on peut en vouloir aux gens qui
nous gouvernent de ne pas avoir le
courage de se poser la question il à
mettre à l'étude
par contre c'est plus compliqué de leur
dire qu'ils n'ont pas le courage de dire
de façon brutale à la population c'est
comme ça que ça va se passer parce que
clairement le problème est compliqué et
que ça va demander du temps d'en faire
le tour
avant d'avoir quelque chose dans
laquelle il quand il part d'enthousiasmé
et d'espoir
kiki qui soit qu'on puisse proposer à la
population
après il y avait une question qui est
une question qui ressemble à la question
sur la taxe carbone qui est une question
sur la tva
pensez vous que la tva soit un outil
fiscal efficace pour faire évoluer les
comportements et renchérir les produits
forts consommateurs d'énergie fossile
tout en allégeant le coût des produits
le vertueux dans la réponse est oui mais
c'est très exactement le principe de la
taxe carbone
le principe de la taxe carbone c'est
très exactement ça c'est de renchérir
les les pays qui est le parent dans les
produits qui sont intensifs en énergie
fossile et comme vous avez pu le voir ça
marche plus ou moins bien alors en fait
la taxe je vais faire un petit couplet
dessus c'est un outil qui est
extrêmement puissants quand vous avez le
temps un exemple qui est bien connu en
france pendant très longtemps vous avez
eue dans un contexte de relative
stabilité des prix en ce qui concerne
les carburants
vous avez eu un différentiel sur le lien
relative c'est plus ou moins 30% mais
c'est parfois distants un sens ou dans
l'autre
vous avez eu un différentiel de
fiscalité sur le diesel qui a fait que
pendant très longtemps le diesel a été
moins cher que l'essence dans ce pays et
bien ce signal prix maintenus pendant 30
ans 40 ans a contribué à faire basculer
en faveur du diesel une fraction
rapidement enfin une fraction
significative du para une fraction
croissante du parc y arriver jusqu'au
moment où le diesel a fini par
représenter 70% des véhicules en
circulation
donc ça marche très bien alors je dis
pas qu'il fallait diésélisé le parc
c'est pas ça que j'en fasse dire je suis
juste en train de dire
voilà un signal-prix maintenue dans la
durée dans vous pouvez constater que il
joue puisque il déforme la structure du
parc de manière extrêmement
significative dans le même esprit les
pays qui ont démarré leur histoire du
pétrole comme producteur de pétrole ont
souvent eu un pétrole qui faisait
l'objet d'une fiscalité domestique très
faible c'est typiquement le cas des
états unis les états unis à l'époque de
l'immédiate avant ou après guerre je ne
sais jamais 39-45 représentaient les
deux tiers de la production de pétrole
dans le monde et à ce moment là où le
pétrole est né aux états unis il faut le
rappeler
ça a été le premier pays producteur de
pétrole pendant très très longtemps et
bien le pétrole était domestiquement
très peu taxé et c'est vrai avec plein
d'autres pays qui ont démarré leur
histoire comme producteur de pétrole
l'egypte l'indonésie
quand les pays ont démarré leur histoire
comme importateur de pétrole ce qui est
le cas de la france en général ils
avaient des carburants beaucoup plus
taxés c'est aussi le cas de la
grande-bretagne qui a des carburants
après taxés comme les carburants alors
que après les chocs pétroliers quand la
mer du nord a démarré son exploitation
et bien les anglais sont devenus
transitoirement pas très longtemps les
transformant exportateurs de pétrole est
bien pour dans le prix des carburants
chesaux il restait très fortement taxés
et bien les pays qui ont fortement taxé
le carburant pendant des décennies ce
qui est le cas de la france quelqu'un la
quasi totalité des pays européens ont
des voitures qui globalement consomme
deux fois moins que les voitures que
vous trouvez aux états unis où le
carburant depuis l'origine n'est pas
taxée ou très peu taxé donc là où vous
avez un deuxième exemple le signal prix
qui a très fortement orienté le
comportement des consommateurs mais
parce que il a été maintenu pendant des
décennies or en ce qui concerne le
changement climatique nous avons des
scientifiques 30 ans pour résoudre le
problème c'est à dire que d'ici à ce que
mes enfants et mon âge qu'il faut que
moi je sois au chômage alors dans 30 ans
normalement je serai au chômage retraite
j'ai beaucoup en retraite y
et avec ce que je viens de dire juste
avant je serai donc chez les enfants et
les en garderait toute la journée mais
donc il faut que le bras climatique soit
réglé si le problème climatique doit
être réglé dans les trente ans voyez
bien qu'on n'a pas le temps d'attendre
un l'effet d'un signal dont la
déformation qui engendre des
déformations très lente donc le la
fiscalité est quelque chose qui doit
être utilisé de manière très ciblée sur
des usages donc il va falloir des formes
et tous les usages très vite et pour
déformer un usage très vite la fiscalité
ça marche pas c'est à dire que si vous
déformez un usage qui est largement
répandue très vite avec la fiscalité
c'est vous rendez les gens insolvables
vis-à-vis de quelque chose qui est
aujourd'hui très largement consommée ça
se révoltent c'est ce qui a eu à petite
échelle avec les gilets jaunes alors y
avait pas que le prix des carburants
dans cette affaire mais si demain matin
vous deviez x
allez je vais dire n'importe quoi à 4 en
10 ans le prix des carburants n'importe
quel gouvernement sont sur une mesure
comme ça alors que c'est à peu près le
genre de vitesse à laquelle il faudrait
aller si vous ne comptiez que sur la
taxe et c'est exactement pareil avec un
certain nombre d'autres produits
si vous voulez que l'empreinte carbone
des français et passe de 10 tonnes à 2
tonnes et donc que ces achats soit
divisée par quatre en l'espace de trente
ans autour baisse de 4% par an il est
bien évident que ça veut dire que vous
devez entretenir une inflation qui n'est
pas là d'une inflation réelle qui se
balade entre 5 et 10% par an sur 30 ans
compliqué sans hausse de revenus 1
vous avez une inflation de 4 à 5% par an
et est revenu qu'ils bouffent pas
pendant 30 ans
j'ai pas complètement sûr qu'aujourd'hui
c'est quelque chose qui va être très
facile à mettre en oeuvre
donc j'étais je suis toujours un grand
partisan de la taxe dans certains
secteurs par exemple sur la production
électrique
ça marche bien d'une manière générale
dans le monde économique qu'on appelle
'b to b' c'est-à-dire business to
business quand vous vendez à une autre
entreprise par des particuliers c'est
quelque chose qui marche très bien aussi
parce que ces ventes là en général une
locomotive une machine à faire des
chaussettes ou un camion sont des ventes
qui sont lentes sert quand vous vendez
d'une entreprise à une autre entreprise
en général le processus de vente est un
processus lent même quand vous vendez
des rouleaux de pq vous faites ça dans
le cadre d'un marché sur les rouleaux de
pq qui va durer toute l'année et puis
vous faire des pâtes les rouleaux de pq
avec vous vendez les serviettes je sais
pas quoi et donc vous avez un acheteur
de rouleaux de pq avec qui vous allez
négocier et le processus est long c'est
pas comme quand vous vous allez acheter
un rouleau de pq au supermarché vous
passez dans les rouleaux et votre achat
dur très exactement 10 secondes
donc là à ce moment là quand vous êtes
dans ces ventes là vous avez la
possibilité de faire rentrer dans la
négociation
un élément qui va être pris en compte
par tout un tas de consultants inutiles
qui derrière vont faire fumer excellent
et donc si vous avez un signal prix très
visibles disant tel truc
au final sur les 20 ans qui viennent va
vous coûter 3 % plus cher que tel autre
truc ça joue comme disent les suisses et
donc ça ça va avoir un ça va avoir un
effet et ça va permettre d'emporter la
décision mais au niveau des ménages ce
n'est pas du tout comme ça que ça se
passe
et donc le la
la taxe n'est pas du tout intégrés dans
des raisonnements terre et donc c'est
l'effet douleur immédiate compter
l'effet de where i media il peut pas
être trop fort sinon le high est trop
élevé et vous sortez comme normalement
donc dans be do i la marche dans canton
quand vous avez c'est en direct au
consommateur ça marche beaucoup moins
bien et en fait ce qui marche beaucoup
mieux quand vous avez su en direct au
consommateur lancée réglementée
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous reste
beaucoup trop peu de temps pour que nous
passions pour l'essentiel par la taxe il
faut passer pour l'essentiel par la
réglementation et il faut donc interdire
obligé ou réglementé normaliser ses lacs
et donc sa demande du courage et sa
demande de faire la pédagogie du
problème et on en revient à ce que je
dis toujours c'est à dire que tant qu'on
a un gouvernement qui est constitué de
comprendre de quel problème on parle d'
idée qui va faire la pédagogie du
problème a malheureusement c'est une
chimère
et donc s'il n'est pas capable de faire
la pédagogie du problème il ne peut
adopter des mesures pertinentes que sous
une pression monstre venant de la
société civile c'est un peu la carte
qu'on essaye de jouer au shift ou qu'une
fois qu'il a laissé la place à d'autres
qui ont peut-être compris le problème
messi met donc et parce qu'il n'a pas le
temps d'apprendre le problème une fois
qu'il est au pouvoir c'est
malheureusement le aussi une loi du
genre
quand vous la regardez la tête d'edouard
philippe la sépaq et la combière de
séduit mais à mon avis ça dépasse pas
beaucoup d'erreurs
donc vous avez vous avez un vrai sujet
pour le courage politique
voilà pour faire un homme d'état il faut
avant tout quelqu'un qui a compris on ne
fouille n'avait pas compris vous pouvez
pas avoir un homme d'état c'est juste
impossible alors dans les dix minutes
qui restent
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je me prends à l'est s'il
y avait une question
[Musique]
il y avait une question sur aia de
questions qui sont liées à l'énergie je
te prendre seul la pour gt prendre cela
pour finir il ya une première question
sur le retraitement des combustibles
nucléaires que je vais prendre une
deuxième sur le pétrole
alors quelles sont les perspectives
possibles pour le retraitement du
combustible nucléaire
eh bien le alors je vais essayer de
ranger les problèmes liés au nucléaire
suis de ma fenêtre
les vrais limitation ou nucléaire pour
moi sont le temps de construction des
centrales
l'intensité capitalistique et en moyens
de la construction de ces centrales
la durée de vie de ses centrales a pas
que ce soit un problème en soi mais je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi et le et la
disponibilité en uranium 235 voilà les
voilà les vrais sujets pour ce qui
concerne le nucléaire
alors pourquoi est-ce que le vrai sujet
c'est la durée de construction et la
durée de vie parce que quand vous
rentrez dans le nucléaire vous y rentrer
pour un siècle quand vous rentrez dans
le nucléaire vous rentrez il vous faut
n'importe quoi entre quelques années et
quelques dizaines d'années pour décider
de construire la centrale
alors encore un programme ça peut être
raccourcie à 0 secondes après il vous
faut quelques années pour la construire
quand vous refaites pour la première
fois comme les français vous pataugez
comme des bêtes et donc à olkiluoto ou à
flamanville dans prenait pour 10 ans 15
ans quand vous êtes un peu plus rodés
comme les chinois ont fait ça en cinq
ans alors le père qui était un nouveau
modèle ils l'ont fait en sept
enfin bon globalement il s'avance mais
quand même ces cinq à dix ans et puis
ensuite c'est un engin qui va
fonctionner 40 à 80 ans voire plus
80 parfaitement
aux états unis où il ya une centaine de
réacteurs en fonctionnement ce qui ne
sont pas arrêtées pour des raisons
économiques parce que c'est pour ça
qu'ils arrêtent en général sont
aujourd'hui tous autorisés par
l'autorité de sûreté a fonctionné 60 ans
tous à l'autorité de sûreté aux états
unis à un système différent du détail du
système français parce que à tout
instant votre centrale doit être
conforme à ses spécifications de départ
alors qu'en france à tout instant et
doit être conforme à l'état de l'art
c'est à dire que à tout instant l'asn
peut dire maintenant toutes les
centrales doivent être équipés de ce si
cela est si vous n'êtes pas équipés de
ce 6e la jeune autorise pas le
fonctionnement aux états unis votre
obligation c'est pas d'être ibid ceci
cela c'est d'être dans l'état dans
lequel la centrale était au moment où
elle est mise en fonctionnement
donc les états unis où une version plus
faible une acception plus faible de la
sûreté que chez nous après on peut
discuter de la quelle est la bonne donc
vous en prenez pour un siècle en gros
quand vous rentrez dans le nucléaire
aucune industrie ne peut en prendre pour
un siècle sans que ce soit une industrie
d'état ou une industrie encadrée par
l'état à laquelle l'état donne des
garanties formelles de pérennité dans
son existence bien vous ne pouvez pas
rentrer dans le nucléaire dans un pays
quel qu'il soit
si vous n'avez pas l'assurance que
l'état va pas vous dire où disant ah bah
tiens maintenant j'ai besoin de fermer
les trois réacteurs
choquée 3% des voix et donc juste c'est
impensable de rentrer dans le nucléaire
si vous avez le moindre risque que
l'état à juhasz janvier si vous êtes un
opérateur privé puis si vous êtes un
opérateur public de toute façon il faut
que l'état s'en mêle donc le nucléaire
est par excellence une énergie qui va
avec une planification d'état par
excellence c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
l'état qui est le plus en pointe sur le
nucléaire dans le monde et de très très
loin
c'est la chine parce que la chine à une
planification d'état biltine dans son
fonctionnement économique
c'est la raison aussi pour laquelle la
france a la plus grande part
d'électricité nucléaire dans son mix
parce que c'est un pays où il fut à
temps et je le regrette pas parce que je
suis vieux mais parce que c'était un
système efficace le
la planification d'état avait toute sa
place aujourd'hui on pense que les
marchés y compris notre cher président
va vous donner toute la vérité sur
l'avenir
on en reparlera des marchés qui vont
vous donner toute la vérité sur la vie
on a déjà fait la connerie dans
l'électricité on s'apprête à la refaire
transport ferroviaire c'est sûr que la
sncf le premier truc dont elle a besoin
en cette année de colis dans le libé à
ses convives crée de la concurrence
juste en fin de marché sur la tête
un point c'est ridiculement je veux dire
je pense que nos gamins ont honte de
nous pour partie en tout cas on mérite
donc le pour en revenir à ce que je
disais c'est vraiment dans les états
très planifiée et un autre état très
planifiée c'est la russie ex urss qui a
aussi une industrie nucléaire très forte
qui du reste comme atom maintenant sdf à
quelques réacteurs en construction chez
rosatom le carnet de commandes s'est 30
ou 40 réacteurs pour les mains vertes
d'une autre je crois qu'ils ne savent
pas trop comment ils vont réussir à tous
tes construit encore il ya des pays par
exemple la finlande quand ton amer doyer
dans notre chantier d'olkiluoto ils ont
pas du tout dit on veut pas de nucléaire
ils ont 10 ans venu du rues du caire sur
le deuxième on va le commander avant cet
homme voilà c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
pour les français il est urgent de
changer ça change
si on y arrive donc le nucléaire est une
énergie d'état par excellence et c'est
son principal inconvénient
ce qui veut dire que dans un monde
libéralisé dans lequel vous dit
messieurs investissez à vos risques et
périls
le nucléaire no way donc il n'y a pas la
moindre chance que le nucléaire soit une
marge de manoeuvre significative dans un
monde qui est libéralisé concurrentiel
où vous avez des risques comme c'est une
industrie à coûts fixes
c'est à dire que vous payez à peu près
tout une fois que le centre à une fois
que la centrale est construite vous avez
à peu près tout payer après derrière
vous avez des frais de fonctionnement et
qui sont marginaux par rapport aux coûts
de construction
ça veut dire que le coût du kaki ce
qu'on appelle le coût du capital c'est à
dire le coût de l'argent que vous allez
devoir trouver pour construire votre
centrale soit sous forme
d'investissements d'actionnaires soit
faux soit sous forme de prêt le fameux
donc les intérêts que vous allez devoir
payer à ces gens là c'est quelque chose
qui est crucial dans le coût du
kilowattheure
je vais vous donner un exemple ait
l'épaule il est connu que le coût du
kilowattheure va dépasser les 100 euros
le mégawatt/heure alors j'ai fait un
petit calcul avec mon petit tableur
excel que je sais encore remaniée à 20
heures perdues même avec un coût de
construction délirant puisque c'est
beaucoup trop cher le p r et bien si le
coût du capital et kate était à zéro
c'est à dire que si on avait donné
gratuitement exactement comme on le
donne gratuitement à l'allemagne
aujourd'hui quand elle emprunte l'argent
pour construire ce réacteur nucléaire
parce qu'on est persuadé que c'est une
excellente chose à faire pour l'avenir
et qu'on a totale confiance dans le fait
que l'état à aucun moment de dire ah non
finalement c'était une connerie on
arrête
et bien si cet argent était prêté à zéro
le mégawattheure de highpoint coûterait
45 euros il va en coûter 120 parce que
l'argent qui est disponible à hinkley
point qu'il n'est pas disponible à 0 il
est disponible à 10%
c'est à dire que chaque année vous allez
devoir payer aux gens qui vous ont donné
l'argent soit sous forme
d'investissements soit sous forme de
prêt
10% du capital restant dû c'est ça qui
fait que le mégawattheure passe de 45
euros à 120 donc en fait l'essentiel de
ce que les consommateurs de ce méga watt
heure vont payer n'ira pas dans la poche
du constructeur de la centrale n'ira pas
dans la poche de l'exploitant de la
centrale
ça ira dans la poche des banquiers et
des actionnaires c'est ça la réalité du
nucléaire dans un état pas dans une
économie où l'état n'assume pas le fait
qu' il en garantit l'existence pendu
très long terme
alors inutile de vous dire qu'en france
même motif même punition comme l'état
près de nucléaire comme une variable
d'ajustement électoral depuis maintenant
vingt ans il n'y a aucune chance que
aujourd'hui vous trouviez des
investisseurs pour investir et si on
crée de la concurrence dans
l'investissement et des opérateurs
privés
le seul résultat que ça va avoir c'est
hier monter le prix du mégawattheure la
concurrence qui va faire baisser
on en parlera tout simplement parce que
ça va faire monter le coût du capital
parce que les gens voudront pas assumer
le risque sans une prime de risque
extrêmement élevé c'est ça le c'est ça
la réalité donc le premier inconvénient
du nucléaire c'est que c'est une énergie
détend et on ne relancera pas le
nucléaire dans un état dans lequel
l'état de 10 parmi nucléaire c'est bien
et c'est pas un peu bien c'est très bien
et comme aujourd'hui on a en france
depuis 20 ans en de pleutres qui traite
encore une fois ce truc là comme une
variable d'ajustement dans un monde dans
lequel ils y ont délibérément la
contrainte du changement climatique du
pétrole qui va se faire plus rares eh
bien on a un système qui cafouille où on
est encore capable
évidemment de maintenir dans de bonnes
conditions les centrales existantes mais
quand il faut je pense qu'il est
absolument urgent que le gouvernement et
que le placent politique redeviennent
responsable là dessus et soit dit en
passant une fois qu'on a dit le
nucléaire c'est bien est d'autant plus
fondée à botter les fesses des gens qui
font n'importe quoi d'autant plus quand
vous dites à vos enfants vous les aimez
c'est plus facile de retirer les
oreilles quand ils ont fait une bêtise
quand vous leur dites que vous les avez
pas plus compliqué
et vous c'est plus facile d'être sévère
avec ses enfants quand ils font une
bêtise si vous les aimez que avec des
enfants qui vous dit que c'est des gens
qui ne sont pas respectables
le deuxième inconvénient donc c'est une
et c'est long à construire et l'ont
exploité c'est simple et c'est très
capitalistique donc ça demande des
courses le deuxième inconvénient du
nucléaire c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
filière que nous exploitons à savoir
l'uranium 235 n'est pas du tout à la
hauteur en termes d'enjeux pour être
capable de remplacer l'essentiel du parc
de centrales à charbon parce que moi
quand je pense nucléaire ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pas d'enfer pour la
beauté de la chose
c est ce qu avec ça je vais être capable
de remplacer les centrales à charbon en
quantités significatives
voilà c'est mon seul ma seule question
le reste je m'en fous donc le en fait
n'en font pas complètement mais pas loin
donc le jeu vous rappelle que la moitié
du parc de centrales à charbon dans le
monde et en chine donc en particulier si
les français peuvent aider les chinois a
remplacé plus vite leurs centrales à
charbon moi je suis très partants pour
ça est plutôt que de donner de l'argent
ou chinois en leur achetant leurs
panneaux solaires
si on donnait de l'argent aux chinois
pour qu'ils remplacent leurs centrales
nucléaires centrales à charbon par des
centrales nucléaires en tant que
contribuable je préférerais de très très
loin je trouverais que l'on ferait
quelque chose de beaucoup plus utile
pour la collectivité
c'est pas rien à ce qu'on a donné aux
chinois dans le cadre des panneaux
solaires français parce que sur les 120
milliards que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
il y en a cinquante ou soixante qui vont
au solaire et sur ces 50 ou 60 qui vont
hausser leur jeu doit avoir entre 10 et
20 milliards qui sont partis chez les
chinois donc pas complètement ridicule
donc on avait de quoi faire de deux ou
trois réacteurs chez eux pour quatre ans
avec le même argent nos impôts qui est
parti chez deux aurait pu faire quelque
chose à mon avis de plus intéressant le
retrait pour le climat et la stabilité
de la génération de mes enfants
en ce qui concerne l'uranium 235 donc
l'uranium 235 ne constituent que 0 7% et
les voies dites de l'uranium qu'on peut
trouver dans la nature
ça fait pas beaucoup par ailleurs du
dernier homme n'est pas un élément
extrêmement abondante dans la nature et
donc le fait de ne se servir que de cet
isotope dans les centrales
c'est quelque chose qui vit
nécessairement la possibilité de
recourir au nucléaire de façon
significative et pour longtemps
pour remplacer le charbon donc pour que
le nucléaire soit durable il est
absolument indispensable de passer à
d'autres technologies de réacteurs à ce
qu'on a coutume d'appeler la quatrième
génération
la quatrième génération en groupe
utilise la capacité que le cas d'uranium
238 à se transformer en plutonium 239
qui lui peut être officio nez ou la
capacité qu'a le thorium 232 qui est un
autre élément qu'on trouve dans la
nature à se transformer en du radium 233
qui lui est fidèle et à partir du moment
où on est capable de maîtriser ce qu'on
peut faire je vais dire après ce genre
de réaction à ce moment vous multipliez
par plusieurs centaines voire plusieurs
milliers
la durée de vie du nucléaire dans le
monde où le nombre de centrales que vous
pouvez construire donc à ce moment on a
quelque chose qui devient une vraie
marge de manoeuvre pour tuer
définitivement charbon dans le monde
jusqu'à ce que l'humanité c'est-à-dire
pour autre chose et ses filières là donc
on appelle la quatrième génération
aujourd'hui l'état vient d'abandonner
quelque part ça par l'état français
alors pour un motif de corps de cu chi
aujourd'hui d'uranium vaut pas cher donc
c'est ça gérer l'approvisionnement
énergétique du pays à l'échelle du
siècle au motif que le prix de marché de
la semaine dernière et pas est bas alors
ça comme conneries vous repasserez mais
j'ai rarement entendu mieux donc en fait
c'est quelque chose qui n'a ni queue ni
tête bien évidemment qu'il fallait quand
il est en fait il fallait continuer en
association avec ce que j'ai évoqué tout
à l'heure je pense que pour la quatrième
génération il faut faire un programme
fasttrack européen avec les anglais les
finlandais les suédois une partie des
pays de l'est et les espagnols voilà
très exactement ce qu'il faut faire
il faut y mettre quelques dizaines de
milliards qui sont beaucoup mieux
employées en france en tout cas et dans
un certain nombre de pays dans le
solaire chinois qui en plus en ce moment
se fait au sol en coin de la forêt pour
fois totalement d'ayant est et avant c
est l'élite dans un certain nombre de
filières alors là dedans dans les
filières qui me semble je suis pas du
tout un spécialiste mais qui me semble
pertinente
il reste l'uranium plutonium à sodium
fondu il ya un certain nombre de
réacteurs en fonctionnement dans le
monde qui ont fonctionné sur cette base
la suppression des inconvénients que
cela présente aussi des avantages
en france on a un réacteur qui est félix
donc c'était un petit modèle de
superphénix qui a fonctionné pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années et qui est
actuellement en cours de démantèlement
et vous avez en russie un réacteur de
cette nature qui aujourd'hui et s'il y a
fonctionné en voiture génère sur
régénération total c'est à dire qu'il
n'a plus besoin d'aucun apport d'uranium
235 pour fonctionner et c'est un
réacteur les projets il est couplé au
réseau qui fonctionne de cette manière
vous avez évidemment les réacteurs à
sels fondus qui sont des réacteurs qui
sont intéressants du point de vue de la
sûreté parce que s'il fonctionne la
pression atmosphérique
il ya de la chimie et du ray traitement
continu qui sont des prêts problème
c'est pas nécessairement le thorium qui
est le plus intéressant dans ses
réacteurs vous pouvez aussi fonctionner
avec de l'uranium
le thorium a des avantages et des
inconvénients et dans les inconvénients
qu'il a il a dans ses produits de
fission donc on a coutume d'appeler les
déchets il a un de ses produits de
fission qui a une radioactivité gamma
extrêmement dur donc ça veut dire que
pour gérer les déchets du cycle
auditorium il faut prendre plus de
précautions que pour gérer les déchets
du cycle de l'uranium
donc ça n'a pas que des avantages de
thorium ça aussi quelques quelques-uns
compliqué mais bon tous ces
inconvénients sont secondaires par
rapport aux risques que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure de se retrouver avec trois
milliards de gens qui vont crever et qui
vont aller voir chez le voisin si quand
même
les conditions ne sont pas un peu plus
clémentes
et tout ça dans un monde dans lequel ce
sera plus difficile de trouver à manger
pense que ces inconvénients du nucléaire
sont totalement marginaux face à la
possibilité d'éviter une partie du drame
que je viens d'évoquer
donc c'est clairement au terme
d'arbitrages de risque que je raisonne
moi le nucléaire et recourir permet
d'éviter une partie du risque du
changement climatique et la totalité du
risque nucléaire c'est beaucoup moins
grave qu'une partie du risque du
changement climatique l'arbitrage est
très vite vu et c'est le père de famille
qui vous parle alors dans les
inconvénients qui n'en sont pas pour moi
et je vais finir par la question des
déchets dans les inconvénients qui n'en
sont pas et c'est justement la question
des déchets pour moi c'est on se fait
peur pour rien c'est les déchets on fait
ce qu'on fait actuellement c'est à dire
qu on les sépare du combustible usé et
on les met dans un trou à 6 géo et voilà
et on les oublie et ça va très très bien
il faut savoir que le plus vieux
stockage de déchets nucléaires dans le
monde il a 2 milliards d'années n'a pas
dit mieux 2 milliards d'années parce que
il ya des réacteurs naturelles qui sont
apparus dans le monde et qui ont
fonctionné il ya des milliards d'années
et ses réacteurs naturelles ont produit
des déchets comme tous les réacteurs que
nous créons aujourd'hui de façon
artificielle
il ya des dai qui a été donné dans une
interview que j'ai donné un mariage est
disponible sur mon site pour ça que
service et ses déchets vont évidemment
aider les télés c'est un boulot si je
puis dire donc ils ont été laissés là où
ils ont été créées il y avait pas
d'homme ya des milliards d'années et
donc on a une vision géologique très
très longue de ce que ça donne de mettre
des déchets dans un doute croûte
terrestre et de voir ce qui se passe
ensuite
donc je n'ai strictement aucune
inquiétude alors vraiment aucune
en ce qui concerne les années qui me
reste à vivre et mes enfants et les
enfants de mes enfants
si on met ses déchets dans un trou à
bure
mais je n'ai aucune inquiétude enfin il
ya des tas de trucs qui me guide
mais alors ça aucune donc on fait ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui on les ont
laissés barragué on les colle en a trop
dans les autres inconvénients du
nucléaire il ya on peut si on veut se
dire que dans la prochaine génération de
réacteurs on fera moins de déchets pose
aucun problème au contraire très bien
donc dans les réacteurs on veut faire
demain un des avantages des réacteurs à
sel fondu aussi c'est que sa racine à m
j'ai envie de dire en ligne de
fonctionnement normal du réacteur une
partie des appels les actinides mineurs
c'est à dire les éléments plus lourds
que le radium qui se forment par
absorption de neutrons dans le réacteur
et qui sont en général radioactifs avec
une radiotoxicité pour certains qui est
élevé il se trouve que ces noyaux là
dans le cadre du fonctionnement normal
du réacteur dont l'inventeur de
quatrième génération
ils sont eux-mêmes cassé par des
réactions de fission donc vous les
trouvez plus une fois que vous sortez le
combustible usé dont vous trouvé juste
des produits de fission comme
aujourd'hui c'est à dire des gros noyau
qui ont été cassés en deux et ça donne
du césium du tout yom de l'yonne comme
ça donc vous retrouver des déchets qui
sont ceux qu'on sait gérer aujourd'hui
est donc comme je leur disais on les met
dans un trou dans les oubliées c'est pas
très grave la géologie sait faire tenir
des choses beaucoup plus longtemps que
les quelques dizaines de milliers
d'années où les quelques milliers
d'années qui nous tétanise la géologie à
ses fesses il a su faire tenir du
pétrole dans des réservoirs alors que le
pétrole c'est liquide pendant des
dizaines de millions d'années donc la
géologie sait faire des choses qui dois
je suis beaucoup plus inquiet encore une
fois des conséquences de court terme qui
vont nous arriver et donc je vais
basculer sur l'autre avec lequel je vais
finir cette petite session questions
que va-t-il se passer sur le pétrole et
est ce que ça va nous poser quelques
soucis dans les années à venir
alors la réponse courte est oui nous
avons obtenu qu'il va y avoir une
publication en fait part le chiffre de
project dans les semaines qui viennent
nous avons obtenu après de longues
négociations et d'habiles négociations
notre chef directeur qui connaît très
bien de pétrole métier aux anneaux avec
pitié dexia perd estat la possibilité
d'accéder à la base de données de tous
les champs en exploitation dans le monde
donc c'est une base de données qui
votera et rachète père normand que nous
avons obtenu pour un tout petit prix
quelques dizaines d'acteurs diviseur de
quelques dizaines
pour accéder à ces données
et ça va nous permettre de voir à quelle
sauce on va être mangés en ce qui
concerne les pays qui aujourd'hui
fournissent l'europe donc aujourd'hui un
tiers du pétrole qui rentre en europe
vient de russie alors si je cumule leur
pétrole et produits raffinés parce qu'on
apporte à la fois du pétrole et des
produits raffinés vient d'europe vient
de russie
vous avez évidemment une partie qui
vient de norvège et de la mer du nord
que généralement un quart du pétrole
mais la mer du nord est en déclin depuis
des années déjà et puis vous avez du
pétrole qui vient d'autres zones et
c'est très marginalement des états unis
si certains d'entre vous se posent la
question
le pétrole de schiste américain il est
pour le moment à exporter enfin marginal
et le la fin l'europe et la france en
importe peu donc on va regarder ce que
ça donne alors ce que ça donne je peux
déjà vous donner la tendance
c'est que pour les années à venir ça
sent pas bon et donc nous allons
effectivement être sous stress
d'approvisionnements pétroliers en
europe et ça va c'est stressant volume
va nous contraindre sur l'économie
européenne et ça va empêcher
même si on n'a pas envie que le que le
la croissance la croissance au club
alors est ce que ceci a un lien avec
cela souvent il ya des gens qui me
disent est ce qu'on peut gérer le
nucléaire dans un monde dans lequel le
pib ces fonds réponse oui
vous savez un pays qui a très bien fait
ça c'est l'ukraine à deuxième pays qui a
très bien fait ça c'est la russie en
ukraine vous avez eu un accident à
tchernobyl en 1986 c'est à dire avant la
chute du mur après la chute du mur le
pib ukrainien comme le pib russe ont été
quasiment divisé par deux mais
l'effondrement économique on va dire
c'est pas à ce moment là vous avez eu
des accidents il ya eu zéro accident en
russie à ce moment là et vous n'avez
plus d'accidents en ukraine après la
chute du mur
donc est-ce que l'effondrement
économique signifie nécessairement et
vous avez également eu le même
effondrement dans les pays baltes est
l'un des trois pays baltes si jamais tel
c'est la lituanie france avait aussi un
réacteur nucléaire
et c'est pas ce moment là que vous avez
eu des pépins donc le nucléaire n'est
pas nécessairement une technologie qu'on
ne sait plus maîtrisée dans un contexte
de contraction du pib
il ya un certain nombre de précédents
historiques qui montre que d'annoncer
plus compliqué que ça c'est pas parce
que le pib baisse qu on est totalement
un foutu de gérer nos réacteurs
voilà je vais m'arrêter là puisque
maintenant il est l'heure de céder la
place aux gens qu'ils causent
traditionnellement à 8 heures
aujourd'hui on n'a ni président ni
premier ministre
donc je vous remercie vivement pour tous
ceux d'entre vous qui ont tenu jusqu'à
maintenant
et puis j'espère que alors je suis
désolé encore une fois pour tous ceux
qui ont des questions qui sont restées
en suspens et je vous dis à la prochaine
fois et bon appétit